This is Jocko podcast number
one 80 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
It was May, 1968
we were triple volunteers.
We'd volunteered and graduated from the
army's parachute jump school at Fort
Benning, Georgia.
Made it through the qualification course
at the Special Forces Training Group in
Fort Bragg, North Carolina,
and after attending the Fifth Special
Forces Group airborne in country training
program,
we had volunteered to serve in
Mac v sogs command and control
during special forces
training at Fort Bragg.
Several of the Green Berets teaching
various courses told us to avoid C and c
because the duty was rough and the
special forces casualties were high in the
top secret unit. Despite
all those warnings,
Rick Howard, John McEntire, Rick Estas,
Tony Horrell, Mark Gentry,
Bob Garcia, Bobby d leathers,
myself and a few others
volunteered to serve in CNC.
I had been in training or in between
training cycles since entering the army on
one December, 1966 in May,
1968 we were finally shifting gears
from being in a training mode to an
operational mode. None of the rumors
prepared us for what followed.
You won't need those. The sergeant
major said, put away all pens,
pencils and notebooks. This
is a top secret briefing.
All of you have either obtained a top
secret clearance or will do so in the near
future or you wouldn't be here.
Welcome to the command and
control detachment of the
Fifth Special Forces Group,
Airborne First Special Forces,
United States Army Special Operations
Augmentation study and observations group
or simply c and C
[inaudible].
Gentlemen before you is a
confidentiality agreement.
You can't tell your
girlfriend, your mother no one.
We were prohibited from writing
anything about the operation,
forbidden from keeping
diaries, taking photos,
making drawings or tape
recordings, notes of any sort.
The sergeant major advised us that anyone
who didn't want to sign that agreement
could leave. Gentlemen,
the sergeant major turned toward
a generic map on the wall.
The North Vietnamese army controls
these neutral countries and pointed to
Cambodia and Laos located to
the west of the Republican's,
south Vietnam and of course
north Vietnam. For several years.
The North Vietnamese army had
moved soldiers, supplies, rockets,
guns and propagandists south into the
eastern provinces of neutral Laos and
Cambodia through an ever increasing
network of trails and roads called the Ho
Chi Minh trail complex.
Now listen up real close.
The sergeant major said,
when you go across the fence, you will
carry no identification of any manner,
shape, or form. That meant
no identification papers,
no dog tags, no diaries,
no photos, no love letters,
and certainly no green berets.
Everyone would wear sterile fatigues
with no company in Signia, no name tags,
no unit designators,
no jump wings or combat
infantry men badges.
Why without giving anyone
a chance to respond.
He said that because Laos
and Cambodia were neutral,
the United States government could
publicly proclaim that the u s reppers
respected that neutrality. Thus,
if we were killed in Laos or
Cambodia or North Vietnam,
the u s government would deny
having anything to do with us.
United States government would explain
that no Americans were stationed in Laos
or Cambodia, which was
technically accurate.
U S government had a plausible deniability
if we were killed or captured and if
captured, we were to
speak a foreign language.
Don't tell them who you are. He ordered,
remember technically under the terms
and conditions of the Geneva Accords,
your status is different than air force
and Navy pilots shot down over north
Vietnam. They're in uniform, they're
identifiable as a u s servicemen.
CNC Men don't fall into the
category of prisoners of war.
We were in effect spies,
although the sergeant
major never used that word.
He also didn't tell us that spies had no
protection under the Geneva Convention
and that we could, some are
laterally be executed if captured
and that right there,
that's some excerpts from the beginning
of a book called across the fence,
which is written by a special
forces soldier in Vietnam named
John Stryker Meyer
and in this particular case it is an
absolute honor for me to say that we have
him here with us tonight to teach us
about his experiences as a member of Mac
resource studies and ops re observations,
command group command and control teams.
Sir,
welcome, welcome to the
show. Glad to be here.
That's quite a welcome. You got there
Vietnam, Huh? Yes. It was quite something.
Absolutely. Then at the time, we
just watched the John Wayne movie,
the Green Berets on top of it
all. So, uh, we were all psyched.
We've seen the movie. We're ready. That's
all it takes. And had been four worn.
You know when you go there,
this is going to happen.
The little guy's going to come out
and ask for people to volunteer.
So we said yeah, right
now when we were done,
it happened before he shipped
us out. A little guy calls out.
We're looking for volunteers and
then a Johnny Mack goes for what?
Sarge can't tell you either
you're in or you're not.
So we raised her hands the next day we
were up in Denang for that briefing.
You covered.
Dang. How well before we get
jumped into that. Yeah. How'd you,
how'd you end up in the military? Where
did you grow up? You grew up in Jersey?
Yeah. Grew up in Trenton, New
Jersey. Uh, dad was a Milkman.
We opened the milk truck and the mom
was the a piano teacher. Choir organist
and, um, um,
after high school took me two years to
flunk out of college upon flunking out in
1966 I was working up at
Yosemite National Park. Yeah.
It was a garbage man farm man
up there. And, um, the book,
the Green Brace came out and my dad had
sent me a letter saying, hey, that's it.
You finally flunked out.
You're going to get drafted.
We got the notification
here from the draft board.
So I read the book and I said,
you know what, if I'm going to go,
if I can get in with these guys,
that'd be a great challenge.
And then if I can do that,
that's the way I want to go.
Because at that time with the army,
uh, eight weeks of basic training,
eight weeks of advanced infantry,
a month leaving, you're in Vietnam,
you can be with any
regular conventional unit.
And by that time there had been
enough stories about some issues, um,
particularly when the,
you were engaged in a regular north
Vietnamese army that Deere have some major
issues and surprises of how
strong the enemy was. So, um,
give me some more training. I needed it.
And W when you were a kid were you, did
you play sports or anything like that?
Yeah, um, I was never that good at it,
but I love baseball was
the head game and football.
And my dad wouldn't let me play a
football to my senior year of high school,
so I had one year of football.
But everything else was just like JV
little league, just loved baseball.
Where did he want you to play football
doing once you get hit in the head too
much? That could be, they
didn't care back then. Did they?
Well, you know what, I
think it was more, well,
in eighth grade I hurt
my knee playing soccer.
I said they were worried about followup
injuries here and still have your body
and Pete one piece when you go to
college or wherever you're going to go,
you know, so, um, they're very
conservative mean. No, my mom,
uh, she's a little farm girl from
Central Jersey and she wouldn't,
she was really unhappy with my
granddad gave me a cap pistol.
So that's the household we
grew up in. But uh, you know,
eventually we went out, learned about
weapons a little bit along the way.
And then of course when this came
along and we got the real deal
and the, the F was so 1966.
So public opinion wasn't completely
against the war yet. Wasn't in 66.
No, but it was beginning. You're
starting, it was starting you,
you had people doing the protest
and letters to the editor
and uh, some of the fringe elms
of society, like we see today.
There's some of those parallels,
but [inaudible] you going
down, how did your parents,
your dad was onboard obviously
cause he sent you the letter saying,
all right buddy, you failed. What
school did you flunk out of? Yeah,
try and stay college. Yeah.
And then, yeah, you just said,
I'm going to go to Yosemite
to be a firefighter. Well,
we had a couple of buddies of mine
that I'd been in college with,
helped me flunk out and we did
much, much serious drinking.
Just the, you know, just stupid young,
young and dumb and no idea what
you're talking about. Yeah.
And uh, so, uh,
they had a crop congressmen that got us
jobs and know [inaudible] it's a good
old Frank Thompson came
through for us. He drove across
and uh, in fact, uh, in Manhattan, Kansas,
we got hit with tornado June 12th
going across the rocky mountains.
We had snow with the back window blown
out a car. So it was just fun. Yeah.
In a nice experience. Again, be
drank a little bit too much there,
but first time, real job,
real money. And then the,
the reality check is just like,
these guys are amazing. If, I mean,
if I can get even close to this,
get the jump school, at least get a,
tasted this. So that was the plan.
How was the, uh, how was the culture
shock when you rolled into two, uh,
army bootcamp?
Well,
by that time I seen a couple dozen of the
movies over time from the World War II
movies. He kind of knew
what was coming. So, um,
early on I had a, uh,
a friend of mine, uh,
whose dad had been in the army.
He goes, look, you'd go in,
just remember this is like a game.
They want to see if they can break you
or not and you just gotta have the right
mindset. And that stuck with me. So
through basic particularly jump school,
they come in and shake out of bed
two o'clock in the morning for bogus
inspections just to see if they could
mess you up or brachy a little bit.
It's kind of like, okay,
we all noticed as a game,
we're all know we're training here. And
uh, so that was the way we move forward.
And you guys could go
right into the, you got,
you could go right into the Q course.
Like you could just do that pipeline.
It was open for you. Well,
because we lost so many people,
they came out with what at that
time we called the baby SF course.
So yes. And even to this day,
some of the guards that went to training
group with are still down at Brag now
training SF guys. And
I mean, we're biased,
but we feel that if you come through
basic advanced jump school and go right
into the Q course and qualify go,
now I have a prequalification,
then your qualification and
then you get to Bray, um,
that there's no bad habits.
Like a lot of the sergeants from the
old days when he came in and you,
you had to be an [inaudible] above
more, more timing grade, et Cetera,
et cetera. And before they be
even consider you. But, um,
they need a bodies. Well, the
guys, again, we're biased.
So then we get the bias out front as the
green kids that came in that went off
and did the job and
eventually it saga, um,
by 68, 69, the majority of the ones,
euros team leaders were young guys.
And there's a lot of us that
either got bored, like in my case,
flunked out for, just
wanted some different,
something different and
said, this is special forces.
And then you get the rumors and then you
finally get to that briefing where you
say, Hey, has a chance to volunteer.
They'll do you realize there's the
highest casualty operation, entire war,
but they forgot to tell you. They
didn't tell you that part. So did you,
did you volunteer for CNC while you were
still stateside or was that once you
got overseas? No, at that time,
the only way you get into special
forces of that program was to enlist for
airborne on assigned.
And then when you went through basic
Dennett advanced infantry, you, uh,
you would be, uh, offered
the opportunity to volunteer.
So during one of the classes
they would have, you know,
like in my case, it was a rainy day.
We're in a gym just like 607 and people
sitting on the floor and it had stage up
front with sidesteps and a cook would
come up to say, hey, the coolest mos,
you'll never go hungry with us. And
they're all fat and slop, you know,
just will cooks. And then other
guys couldn't for Camo, Intel, mps,
that kind of stuff. At the very end,
this little banty rooster
comes in and it was raining.
So every bottles had arraign jackets and
stuff on as banty rooster comes in with
a Bray, his and his fatigues are wet.
He came up and did a straight jump
onstage, turned around and said,
um, we're looking for recruits for special
forces, if you, if you're interested,
see me outside fact, anybody
interested? Well Hell, I read the book.
I jumped up off the floor,
me about three other guys and the other
700 just sat down going like, WTF,
you guys had gone to
nom to a couple weeks.
I'm going to give just a little bit
more training here. It was just amazing.
So he jumped off the stage and that's it.
So he ran us through the psychological
tests, had to show we could swim,
run all that stuff. And were
you a calm guy initially?
Did you get trained as
a calm guy? Yes he is.
Do they still call 18
echo back then or knows?
This is pre historic gunfire
forest. The forest is the,
a SF designator. Got It. And
Oh five B is Comma Morris Code.
And then after training group we sent,
they sent us down for 12 weeks to Fort
Gordon for RTT cause they need a lot of
AA camps and core c and c needed
some RTT operators, radio teletype.
And so that was the extra training
and that's where I got busted.
Me and Johnny McIntyre got
busted down to private e Dukes.
So we landed a non words you
what'd you do to earn that?
Oh well we're just assholes really. I
mean these are, these are butter bars too.
Young, new tennis. They get this company
and here come these green berets.
We just got done all our training.
We're official green barrettes right.
You're the baddest man on the planet
here. I still read your buddy.
So what? I have my
article 15 with the CEO.
I go in and there's eight article
fifteens on the tail. He says, pick one.
I've picked one, scratched it up and
threw it out because you got nine. Now
I've got me and Maca target busted. So
as he deuce landed the knobs and he dues.
Yeah. So he gets it. So,
so it wasn't till you got to Vietnam,
correct? That you heard about CNC or, no,
you said some training instructors
do Combo, well you know here,
one of these little sidebars
and we go through Camo, myself,
McIntyre and a few of us got recycled
because you had to get up to a,
I forget 12 or 15 groups
[inaudible] or something. Yeah. WPS.
I had to with the seal team,
I went to a course like when the last
guys that were learning Morse code and we
had to get whatever it was, I think we
had a lower standard than that cause we,
cause it wouldn't just, no
one would if you want to,
even my officer then couldn't
give you the officer out.
So no, but we,
one of our guys who took us under
his wing was a guy named Paul Villa.
Rosa SFC been a non three times,
had a little tattoo around his neck
cut here. And uh, but he, he helped us,
he got us gone. So in our mind,
he, and we had a Weidner and Russo,
two other instructors for two oh five B
and so one day got to know us near the
end. It's like, hey, you guys go,
don't do it as foul to your stuff.
Get an AA camp, learn about the
people, Blah Blah, blah. Okay.
That's what it came down to.
So when we get that briefing
and the top secret briefing,
and one of the first things we hear about
from Scuttlebutt Paul Villa Rosa was
Kia the first Kia out of
a fob four at the time,
which was in January of 68 so here's one
of our living legends who got us in the
SF, trained us up is Kia.
And that had us talk
about psyops. It hit hard,
but you, but so that was in Vietnam
when Nate for when they now said to you,
okay, do you want to be a
part of this other program?
Do you want to go one more volunteer
route? And ended up here? Yes sir.
Of course you're like, yeah,
let's bring it, let's go
young and dumb. And then, so then,
so then you immediately got assigned,
they said right away to test to screen
you or anything. Any, anything else?
They just said, oh cool. Or you're,
you're smart enough to volunteer. Yeah,
I've got a vet. He had been done and uh,
all of us either had the top secret
or it was in process. And so,
uh,
from near literally the next day of
plaintiff Denang up north and then we had
the briefing and uh, and of course,
you know, we had a safe house.
The denying where does there's house 22,
that's our safe house and welcome
to special forces, you know.
And that was a safe house.
It was run by either
us or s agency or both.
And um, you know, you'd go
in and here's old SF guys.
In fact it was one of the teams just got
back from trying to rescue one of our
hatchet forces
and they're just sitting there to talk
about the combat and Maca and [inaudible]
oh shit, we're going to really die.
It's a good thing we
spent our money cause we,
cause when we were going through the a
r t t training, we had a weekend pass.
We'd go up and we were in Washington.
When we see the Tet offensive and
the tanks are running over Lang VA,
the AA camp at Line Bay
one oh one and we go,
we know we're going to die with high
degree of certainty. So we went home,
took our money out of bank,
all of our principal earns with $1,000
we ate steak dinners until he went to
Vietnam.
So there'll be worth this house 22 and
we're thinking about the same thing as
guy. Oh Shit. We're really into
it now. And so we'd go upstairs,
take showers in the showers.
A couple of these hookers that are
in there do Chanel would with coke,
Coca Cola and they're cleaning
up. Just like welcoming you here.
A couple of guys getting a load in the
back there and they're all pumping away.
It's like, oh this is really cool.
It tells but this side of Vietnam,
here we go. Yeah. So bring
it on. We're ready. And then,
and then you talked about that flight up
to the first place you got assigned to
us. It was fob one
[inaudible] we was called fob.
Where you guys call it a [inaudible]
generation. I guess we're,
I guess we're cutting
corners over here. Okay,
so you're going to fob one caught
anything to like still get your leaf to
supper? Well, there's a
whole, there's a whole lot,
there's a whole offshoot of the
word fob, which we turned into fob.
Have you ever heard the term
fob it before? Yes. Yes.
So someone that stays on the
fob and never goes out. Yeah.
So notice if rents, yeah,
well, yes, the ramps is,
is is what you guys called them.
And I don't know if the name
of my consulting company
is echelon front and the
reason we called the company echelon
front is because we wanted people to know
that we were the guys that were like
in the front, not the, not the ramps,
which is specifically taken from
David Hackworth book. Indeed.
Read a ton of times up. Me
Too. How was it? Yeah. Awesome.
And flying up into fob one. Right.
With the King B. Yeah. How was that?
It's just another day in
the secret war, you know,
because they had the old eight-thirty 30
fours and so the pilots set up high and
then you had the, the, the uh,
apartment in the back for the
passengers and there's a door gunner.
So when Mack attire, me and John, uh,
Hutchens get on the eight 34 is
the door is only on the right side.
So we all get in and I see
the helicopter polygon.
I mean the gunner gone was
the gunner Vietnamese. Yeah.
This is all Vietnamese [inaudible]
were you, were you ready
for that? Mentally? Not at
all. Okay. Cause like, yeah,
cause I guess one more important
note to make to everyone so that the,
the aircraft is being flown
by a Vietnamese pilot with
a Vietnamese copilot and
a Vietnamese gunner.
Yeah. It was the two 19th,
a special operations squadron for the
South Vietnamese Air Force and uh,
all pilots. And so, you know,
our training was, we are going
to work with the people there,
the indigenous people.
But when you literally climb it to
their helicopter and your life is now in
their hands, that's like, you know,
we did upgrade, you messed the code,
didn't really think about it much,
but it was taken us a couple
steps jumping in and going like,
now WTF to what's going on here now. I
thought we have, you know later he you,
he like we've seen in the
movie with John Wayne,
they all had you is not this old age 30
force of course keep thing, you know,
and that has it in the engine and
that was a be 17 a rotary engine.
Yeah.
And then we're going to get into the
factor of how those guys prove themselves
over and over and over and over again
to be just incredibly brave and not,
not just incredibly good pilots,
but just brave beyond comprehension.
When you were fine up there, was it,
was it a mellow flight
up there or was it cool?
Yeah, it was a beautiful day. You
know, it's warm, like it's always hot,
but once you get air you get to flow.
You know how it is when
you were flying through.
And we go on over to cemeteries
and everything and we're
going down highway one,
which is heading north
from Denang up to food buy.
And we went past the food by airport.
And so we're flying north when the west
side of the highway one and you see the
airport and then there's this big
compound, which was the second, uh,
Arbonne division training cramp company.
And then all of a sudden it's like you're
flying north and then you're on your
side looking straight down at the rail.
You did a 90 degree flip
as it begins to turn.
So I seen the guy talking the door
gunner, like doing this crunchy thing,
you know,
could we all had our new fatigues and
you could just tell where newbies,
disgusting newbies. Green
asked me grays, man,
this guy's going to have his kick.
So I was kinda thinking something's
going to happen. What is it? Well,
Maca targets gs and
Hutchins goes the same way.
And I watched the guy,
so we did the, you know,
you look down, there's the road.
And the first time we'd had a helicopter
with that kind of a radical ride.
And so he did a one 80 then came
back and did a three 60 and landed.
We get off while we get off and
then a recon team gets on disappears
was that, was that spike team
Idaho that got on right. Okay. So,
so that happens the ones year as the
bracelet right there and that does,
you got off that bird that
brought you into fob one and,
and it was despite team
Idaho that got on board.
Yup.
Cleanline was the one zero and Robert
own was the one one with four indigenous
troops were five indigenous troops
and and so you start your checking
and whatever and then whatever,
however many hours goes by and all of a
sudden what's happening on camp when you
start to realize that
something's gone sideways.
Well, you know, I was very fortunate
and went with B training group.
I was a catcher and play center field,
a company softball team and we
went on to feed at that summer.
And the reason why spider parks,
Robert J spider parks was our pitcher.
And that little skinny
ass Texan could bring it.
And we still played fast pitch
none of this wimpy slow-pitch shit.
And so we won our games. And
uh, so I come in, we land Mack,
Tara and I are in Hutchinson and we're
like literally walking in front of the
[inaudible] office.
Just had a long road that went from
highway one east into the compound.
The training centers on the right saw new,
we hear to Vietnamese and we
hear a Cambodians on the left.
If you go down and we get
in and take our stuff out,
we're just standing looking stupid.
And then here comes spider parks and
it's like, Whoa, am I glad to see you?
Could we use it? We were
both in a company together,
spent many months there
training up before we came
and now he, but he wasn't the one
that told you what was going on with
no cause, right at that point it was
like, hey, and I got a spirit bunk.
If he goes in and talks to the
sergeant majors as I noticed, asshole,
I'm gonna bring him in with
me for a couple of days.
And we'll see what's going to happen.
Cause at that point a
spider had been on Idaho,
had run four or five missions with the
sergeant lane and then Lane said you're
ready for your own team.
So he promotes them off,
they appoint them as a one zero.
And so he was in that interim time waiting
for the transition to come where he's
going to get assigned a team. And uh,
so he's in base team goes out.
So he's got a high degree of
interest in what their statuses.
So the Mr First Kamel check, they
gave a team. Okay. Which in our case,
once you're on the ground,
usually wait about 10 minutes to see
what's going on around you gave a team.
Okay. Then the assets leave cause
they can't stay that long anyway.
At least the helicopters
that they had back
which the team. Okay. Was a break
and squelch on the radio. Right.
Generally Joanie
speaking. Yeah.
Those either don't know. What
that is is when you break,
we squeeze the handset on the radio.
It made, you can tell on the other end.
Okay. They just purposefully
squeezed that microphone three times.
We know that that's the
signal for okay. Right.
And sometimes like early on,
the guys may say, um, Timo k.
But yeah, later on I saw it was just
Sprake break and then they say, okay,
then Covey will leave.
So they were in and then spider
came back later. He goes, hey,
we haven't heard from Idaho.
So by dinnertime, hey,
we haven't heard by head Oho
we haven't heard from them.
We're really concerned about what's going
on here. And then by the morning, uh,
they're still at that
point, not, not a word.
And W at what point did you guys get word?
I know I'm hazy on how many, what the
day or timeframe was, but eventually, uh,
another day decided that
had been too long. No Camo.
They put in what they call bright light,
which is a team that's goes
into either find the other team,
if there's casualties or down pilots.
That's what the light mission is. Word
Down Pilots, uh,
bring relief or just bring casualties
out or help people get the team out.
The wound, the team. So they went in a
team, new went in, everybody was wounded.
One guy was killed. This is
from the team that went in,
went in for the bright light. This
is, this is a Oregon, correct? Yeah,
with a Mike Tucker and um, and
George the troll Sternberg.
They went in and at one point
they were thrown a hand.
They were in a bomb crater and so the
NVA were hitting them with our weapons
car. 15 fire. They had
our m 26 fragment aides,
one of which blew off
George's jungle boot solid.
These guys are really banged up pretty
bad when they came out and when they got
out
and they, but they didn't find
anybody from Idaho. Correct.
I'm going to take it back to the
book here. This is sort of the,
this is, this is the
reaction back at fob one.
When Oregon comes back back at base,
there was a collective sigh of relief
that s t Oregon had survived the short
lived but furious but ferocious bright
light mission. The loss of Estee,
Idaho, however, hung over the
camp like an invisible fog.
Spider was the first person I
spoke to. After that bright light,
he went straight to the bar,
unable to believe that STI,
Idaho advantaged the complete lack of
clues added to the mystery where they
killed, where they wounded, captured,
and now prisoners of the NBA McEntire
voiced everyone's next thought before he
be captured by the NBA. He said he'd
kill himself with around from his car,
15 or pretend to be dead and blow up as
many NBA as possible with one final hand
grenade.
There was no doubt in my mind I'd never
be taken alive from that day forward.
I always carried an m 26 frag grenade
on the upper hook of my web gear.
It was the last one I'd used, I would use
welcome to c and c McIntyre muttered.
We had heard about s t ASP from fob for
vanishing and Laos presumed Kia on 28
March, 1968 but there were others.
Sergeant First Class, Robert
L. Taylor killed four April,
s t bear from fob three Kia,
Laos major George Cuomo. You.
17 crashed, died 14 April fob,
five base spike team
members, Sergeant FirstClass,
Leroy and right and Staff Sergeant
Lloyd f Lasalle Kia Fish Hook area of
Cambodia. Two may fob,
two based Lieutenant
Joseph C Shreve Kia
hatchet force operation.
One may fob one based s t Alabama team
members specialist fifth class Kenneth M,
crying at Private First
Class Paul Chester King Kia,
a Shao target for May fob one hatchet
for Sergeant First Class Ronald J.
Miller k 12 Mae fob, one based Master
Sergeant Robert D. Plato in first and
Sergeant First Class. John Hartley,
Robertson k a king be
helicopter crouch crash.
Laos 20 May. Additionally,
five SF troops were killed at Fox fob
three from mortar and artillery shrapnel
between 15 and 21 April,
1968 specialist fifth class,
Charles m Corey specialist,
fifth class, Daniel F. Sandoval,
Sergeant Dennis Thorpe,
sergeant first class, Stephan
Mazac and specialist fifth class.
Samuel R. Hughes.
Yeah,
McEntire and I didn't
personally know any of the Kiis,
but the sheer number in that
short period of time was sobering.
Most of them were veteran special forces,
soldiers being as green as we were,
made us all the more nervous but
not scared enough to quit CNC.
That's uh, that's,
that's quite the, quite
the welcome aboard.
Oh yeah. And then do one little
side note on spider parks. Um,
on that bright light when a team came
out there was so shot up because one of
the team members got decently wounded on
the distraction that they never gave a
team. Okay. Spider went
down with a King B separate.
King B got out looking to make
sure everybody was out and he took,
they took a tense fire that king B got
fired up and on extraction the door
gunner was Kia on that. So spider was um,
quite a mess when he got back.
[inaudible]
yeah, that's, that was such a short period
of time to be losing all those guys.
That's a matter of months.
Oh yeah. And we left several out.
Um, so these, uh,
these spike teams going in explore,
will you explain a little bit about
what the spike teams were like?
What it consisted of?
The spike teams was a code
name for our recon teams.
You had two basic elements
with CNC to hatch, a forest,
which could be a company platoon
or a company size operation.
And then the recon teams,
which we had would be two
or three Americans with a,
the corresponding number
of indigenous troops.
So initially we ran three Americans with
three south Vietnamese and the South
Vietnamese on our team were really
good. And then later they're so good.
I just ran myself
one on one, one with four ditch and uh,
we trained up heavily particularly
up to that. And then, uh,
um, learn who the best ones were.
And we had a couple of the guys who had
been like Hep or interpreter Soule who
had been near date men running
missions for over two years by 68.
So they were highly respected. In
fact, um, only by the grace of God,
they warn on the team that disappeared
cause we were able to build around them.
Hmm.
You have this other part in the book here.
This is another sort of
welcome to fob one. During the,
during the first few weeks in fob one,
I attended at least three memorial
services for fallen SF comrades.
Services were held in the mess hall.
The last one I attended was for
lane and Owen's during the service,
the chaplain hesitated on Lane's name.
This was the last official function
honoring spite team, Idaho's members.
And the chaplain couldn't
remember lane's name.
I didn't care if he had attended a dozen
memorial services for other branches of
the military that day. I was so angry.
I never attended another
memorial service. That fob one.
The services soon stopped anyway
because there were so many casualties,
no official announcement.
They just stopped.
Oh yeah. You and I were
talking a little bit about, uh,
Ramadi when we were in
Ramadi and the, you know,
one thing that we started
doing immediately was going
to the memorial services
of the soldiers and marines
that were getting killed.
And that was a big wake up call
for everybody. Uh, I can tell you,
I don't think probably anyone in
my task unit had ever been to a,
yeah,
I had ever been to a memorial service
overseas for guys that have been killed.
I mean, and here we were. There
were, they were happening every day.
You never think about it. No.
Until you're there now and you guys
were having so many casualties that they
just said, okay, well we're not
even going to have them anymore.
Ah,
here's talking about some of your first
few operations that you went on and I
don't think I've talked about this,
but so these little teams that you had,
yeah. These little teams,
we're getting into helicopters
and flying over the fence,
which means over the border into Laos
and Cambodia to do reconnaissance pretty
much in the middle of
nowhere by yourselves.
Correct.
This type of operation in present
day is not very likely to happen.
The, the amount of risk that
you guys were taking. It's,
it's crazy to read about, like my,
my personal contingency that I'm
running through my head. You know,
what if this happened, what if that
happens? Right. I'm looking at these same,
yeah. If I was the commander
in charge, I'd say, well,
you need to come up with a better plan.
You need to come up with something
where we have better backup,
especially when the situation is because
you guys can get air support and you
guys used it heavily. But yeah,
as soon as the weather rolled in,
it was like you guys are out
there on your own. And I mean,
we'll get into some stories where
you're out on your own for sure.
And you know, and uh, um, is that,
that element of it is, uh, an extra
contingency. We had no artillery,
no traditional army or Marine Corps
support and of course no seal teams.
Yeah. They were busy doing this
stuff on the coast. And uh,
so it was quite something to go
across the fence. And in a way,
we're flying into the 18th century
because everything was so old,
the way of working. And they said
do slash and burn agriculture.
So you'd come in with a helicopter,
everybody would hear you comment and the
local people had to cooperate with the
NVA or because their model was work
with us or we're going to kill your dumb
ass. So, um, the game was on
and the purpose of most of these was
to figure out where the trails were,
what was being transported, where
the location of enemy personnel,
where it was bay. It was your basic
reconnaissance missions, right?
Well, in addition to, yes,
that was the first part.
So you always had general missions,
either a point mission a cause.
By the end of 68, they were
building fuel lines from the north.
They were coming down near gone
across the DMZ river in Lagos.
And uh, so we heard reports about that.
So that could be a point mission or a
general [inaudible] where the movement's
gone, what supplies are and
then wiretaps peel w snatch.
And um, those were the
other missions. And so our,
our south Vietnamese are
trained, we trained them up.
So back then we had stayed
Yardi cassette player, right.
And South could climb up a telephone pole,
hook it up and it covered a
wire all the way up with mud.
So if anybody walked past,
they would never see that
wire and we would record,
cause the CIA told us if you record,
even though you don't hear anything,
keep it on. Cause we get
this taste back to us,
we're going to amplify it a hundred times
because the north Vietnamese phones,
even though we're in the
cradle, there is still on and,
and we could record it
date amplifying that.
You hear people talking in the
background, get into off of that.
So those are some of the other missions.
So you start going on your
first few operations here. Um,
and by the next morning, back to
the book, by the next morning,
the weather had broken and we were
inserted smack dab in the middle of the
biggest road running north to
south through the a Shau Valley.
Am I saying that right?
Asheville Ashaw valley. Uh,
there was no jungle. There were hundreds
of bomb craters of various sizes.
But what surprised me the most was the
number of Punji pits that we passed.
Some were huge,
large enough for animals and you go
through this mission is one of your first
missions and there's
like no enemy contact.
And one of the guys who
are with walking in,
I looked at each other
in complete disbelief.
We had just walked down into the valley
of the shadow of death without seeing
one NVA soldier spider joke with me
saying that I was one of the few people in
the history of CNC to have a run,
a practice mission and two missions
and still have not gotten the combat
infantry men's batch,
the award given to soldiers who had
seen combat with the enemy or were under
direct hostile fire.
I kept telling myself that this was a
fluke and I remembered what the special
forces trainers told us at Fort Bragg,
the NVA and the Vietcong guerrillas will
fight when they want to know sooner.
So your first couple of operations, you
got pretty uh, pretty lucky. Oh yeah,
we're a slitter snails not wounded. Could
we put it in those air force sensors?
And then we had all this heres tack air
stacked up because we just figured it's
going to be a shit show. Nothing
happened. So we left out some poor guy,
supportive VA gunner opens
up with a 50 caliber.
They killed him several times man.
The napalm bombs cause they want to
use something on this big mission.
Where you uh, the other interesting
that you talk about in the book, uh,
I don't think it was one of yours,
but even when you guys would do
training missions over there,
there was like a potential for enemy
contact on your training missions.
Absolutely. Yeah. Lynne black and
his team, they ran a heavy contact.
In fact it was the navy to save their
dumb ass at one training mission cause
they just happen to have the frequency
to kink bees couldn't get in and they
called the navy and they came
out of a big boat. Yeah. Yeah.
Some kind of boat that's really long.
But he came in and pulled her ass out
cause they the via Kaya must've a couple
hundred people who were coming after and
they were just out trying to do like a
shakeout patrol. Just a little
training operation. Yeah,
just a little in country thing.
You know this is just go train,
get a couple of days, get out of camp,
eat some Eastland loops, have some fun.
Okay, well you're a,
your luck didn't hold up.
I guess going back to the book
and is this guys named south?
Am I saying that right? Perfect.
Okay. Bye now. So eyes were sow's.
Eyes were bigger than sauces. So
you've been inserted and now you,
you're starting to have a
situation unfold. If you
raised spider walk and said,
tell him I'm declaring
prairie fire emergency.
If he says anything about not hearing
any gunshots, tell him to fuck off.
I'll explain later. Sal's never
been wrong. Look at him as we spoke,
sal looked at us. Boku VC Beaucoup,
VC call King B's now he whispered.
And then you get on the horn. I have a
prairie fire emergency team in distress.
I have a prairie fire
emergency. Can anyone hear me?
I spoke in a hushed tone with my hand
cupped over the mouth. The radio.
I looked at my watch.
We still had more than a hundred minutes
before our next scheduled Camo check
with spider at 1600 no one responded.
So the,
the deal with calm windows are back in
the day when we had batteries that would
run out.
You couldn't just sit there and monitor
the radio all the time on either side.
[inaudible] people that were
waiting for you to call,
they'd be waiting and they didn't want
to, they wouldn't monitor the whole time.
So they would come up at certain
predesignated communication windows.
So that's what's going on here.
You have this bad situation
unfolding and you go to call,
but they're not particularly
listening in at that moment,
which is why no one's
responding. Right. Yeah.
I'm just explaining that to some
folks that because nowadays we have,
well first of all, we have cell
phones. When we call anyone,
whenever we want to make
some nice ring tone.
And you've talked to everyone through
and even when I got in we had calm
windows. Yeah, yeah, we, yeah, we set
up call. I was a common guy too. Sure.
Yet we set up calm windows
and we'll call you, you know,
whatever it was every
two hours or whatever.
And that's the situation
that's unfolding right here.
You guys still hadn't been
contacted yet. So back to the book,
I sat down with my back against the PRC
25 and opened a can of Apricot's I was
facing south and just starting
to sip the sweet apricot nectar.
When all hell broke loose,
the green jungle around us are ruptured
with definitely full automatic blasts
from NVA, AK 47 and our car fifteens
because my back was to them,
I hadn't seen Sal's warning gestures
or watched him get the jump on the
approaching NVA.
I remember spilling apricot
nectar on the stock of my car.
15 as I turned to my left
where the majority of the
NVA gunfire was coming from
foolishly,
my first thoughts were that I would have
to clean off the nectar off my weapon
and not spill the entire Canada, Africa,
Apricot's because I had waited
so damn long to eat them.
They were always a treat in the jungle.
But the initial seconds of the
firefight, I remember Sao and,
how do I say his name? Fuck
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck. Yelling.
Pro-Family profanities at the NBA
as they fired on full automatic,
the crack of AK 47 rounds had
never sounded louder or closer.
All I could see from our perimeter was
Gunsmoke the red and orange blasts coming
from the darker than ever.
Green jungle and the green AK 47
tracers flying over our heads.
In an odd sort of way, there was
an eerie beauty to the scene.
The funder's fury of dozens
of men blasting away at
each other on full automatic
within 10 feet of each other, killed all
other sounds. The eardrums were numb.
Adrenaline had slammed into
our bloodstreams and was
now screaming through our
systems. It heightened all senses.
It extended time. For example,
a car 15 fires, 20 rounds of five,
five six high velocity ammunition
in less than one and a half seconds.
Yet those first opening moments of combat
with the NVA seemed much longer than a
half a second. Then the second and a
half. Ordinarily when firing on full
automatic,
the weapon expended rounds quickly and
we trained ourselves to try and gauge
when that last round in the magazine
was slamming into the receiver.
Some men placed to trace around
in the magazine as a visual cue.
During that firefight, it seemed
as though I counted the rounds,
leaving the car 15 and knew exactly when
the 18th and last round was exiting the
weapon. Also, during
that first experience,
exchange fork was slightly behind me to
my right and since I was on the ground
he was firing over my shoulder.
That exposed my right ear to
almost a full blast from his car.
15 the explosions were
painful, but fox saved my life.
I had aimed the car 15 down the hill.
Toward the largest number of AK 47 muzzle
flashes that I could see to my left.
What I hadn't seen were a handful of a
handful of NVA soldiers who broke out of
the jungle to the right
and it opened fire on us.
Folk realized I hadn't seen the
NVA troops coming up the hill,
so we got to my right and blasted
them back into the jungle.
I was so focused on the first muzzle
flashes that I completely missed the
others. If those NVA soldiers
had advanced a few more feet,
we would have been history and the
remainder of the team which was on my left
would have been at risk.
That time warp continued when everybody
ran out of bullets simultaneously.
The only audible,
the only sounds audible were the metal
clips of cold magazines being slammed
into hot machine guns and bolts
slamming shut to resume the firefight.
A key element in any firefight
is the race to reload.
After the initial
contact on seven October,
1968 s t Idaho won the race.
No one was faster than Sao heap.
Hip Hip folk at getting
the first magazine out,
the second one in and returning full
automatic gunfire on the enemy within
seconds. We had gained fire superiority,
the months and months of training on
the range under the tutelage of spider,
spider and Walken, all
of the live fire drills,
all the live fire races to see who
finished reloading first paid off.
All other games in life were frivolous
and irrelevant in this deadly game.
If you missed hitting
the target, you died.
So that was your first big contact, Huh?
That was it. That's a
doozy. It was absolutely.
And uh, it still sticks with us, you
know, you know, never forget it and fuck.
I mean later on we're back in base.
I was complaining cause I didn't
realize what had happened.
And so talking through Hap, the
interpreter said, you dumb fucker.
I just saved your ass.
These guys would come up the hill and
you're too stupid to realize it. Oh,
so you were mad at him for students who
goes to year, could my ears just fuck,
I couldn't hear for days. It's like,
so thanks for saving my life.
I'm complaining, right? Oh,
classic. Oh yeah.
You continue on with this a little
bit as as we gained complete fire
superiority. I on the URC
10 beeper and started screaming into
the PRC 25 I have a fucking prairie fire
emergency. That bitter fear laced plea
was greeted with complete silence.
Wolken was less than subtle. Keep
yelling until you get someone.
A key factor in STI,
Idaho's favor that day was the small
knoll that woken has driven us to.
The jungle is so thick and the knoll was
so small that only a score of NVA could
rush at once. They weren't moving,
they weren't fast moving fear,
inspiring charges that the NBA were known
for successfully executing either here
or the jungle worked against
them, but the NVA kept coming.
At one point woke and pulled me over,
pointed into the jungle and said, look,
they're stacking up dead bodies
to get to us. Hip showed me,
can you believe it? And they keep
coming. Hell, if we kill enough of them,
the body stack will be as high as we are
because the jungle area was so dark at
first. I couldn't tell exactly what I
was looking at. But woken was right.
The NVA were stacking bodies
and firing at us from behind.
They're dead comrades.
A lot of NVA soldiers died in those
first few minutes of hell on earth.
It's a determined enemy. Oh yeah.
And we heard about, you know,
it's one thing that do hear
about it basic and, and, uh,
special forces training, how
determined the enemy was.
And uh, to see it
firsthand dying like that,
I mean literally just kept coming
and we had high ground, you know,
thank God for high ground, the thick
jungle and the fact that it wasn't a,
a big, big area where he could mass more.
Did you guys didn't bring a, you guys
didn't have an automatic weapon with you.
You guys didn't have an AWS like
I had like a belt fed machine gun.
You guys wouldn't carry those?
No, we had a sit,
well nick k six man team and the teams
on the teens began carrying the a m 60 a
little later. And then, uh,
the RPG cause the cut the
barrel off and it had the, um,
the magazine of the, uh, circular, um,
magazine, the hills things too hard,
250 rounds. But they were some
that did it. But in our case,
because we cardium 79 also to Sawed-off
m study nine or collect gave you a lot
of extra firepower.
Did you use the full shat rounds
with that or just the, just the
brown would be fleshed yet.
So if anything was close,
that would be the first round. And that
we need the hes, we had the rounds,
but no, AWS man, that's it. This I,
when I hear that story right there,
I would do anything to have an m 60
machine gun in the situation. Absolutely.
The weight, the rounds and everything
else. You know, like in my case,
I carried the radio,
always cared to radio and so between the
radio to battery and we always had 600
plus rounds.
We were, um, we, I was on
my first deployment to Iraq.
I was on like one of my first patrols
in Humvees and we were out and we,
we ended up, we hit
a, uh, a little, I dunno what you
call them, the steel hedgehog.
Do you know what that is? It's
like a little obstacle, right?
That Americans had put out American
didn't put it out a steel hedgehog.
A little,
it's like a little obstacle for those of
you who don't know it's to prevent cars
from going by. Well, we were, we,
we made a wrong turn somewhere and we
went down a road we weren't supposed to go
to and we hit a one of those
little steel hedgehogs.
We didn't know what it was.
So we're driving along,
he's actually my Humvee too,
and it, it made a loud noise and sparked
and I actually thought in my mind,
I thought we just got
hit with a low order IUD,
like a low order Boothby booby
trap that didn't fully explode.
So we come to a stop and we all get out
of the vehicles and now we're in the
middle of Baghdad. And then
we're just surrounded by threats.
And in our mind we're
about to be attacked.
Cause we didn't know that we had
just ran over our old American thing.
But we're two still still. You
don't know. We don't know that.
So everyone's out there and we're
off there with our, with our m fours,
our little basically car fifteens.
Yeah. And you like, I felt,
I felt completely naked. I was
saying to myself, God, we don't like,
we need better weapons now. We had 50
cals mounted in the Humvees, but you know,
once we were mobile, I'm thinking we do.
Why don't we have, why don't we have,
you know, belt fed machine guns. When
I got, when we got back that night,
it wasn't just me that felt like, cause
that because that night all my guys,
they went in every Humvee, everyone put
belt fed machine guns, we mounted them,
we staged them. So anytime
we got out of those vehicles,
we were ready to go to war. Oh yeah, yeah.
Protecting a situation like that because
you could have on limits that people
come in nuts, but yet
that naked feeling. Yeah,
cause an a w in a situation
like this roof. That'd be nice.
Going back to the book
for more than an hour,
my cries and screams into the radio
and the URC 10 beeper went unanswered.
As the NBA mounted more attacks,
there was no need for
radio secure procedures.
Now the hide and seek
portion of the game was over.
Now it was simply a matter of
survival. My respect for the NBA,
his tenacity grew that day, but the hill,
the jungle and our car fifteens worked
against them as they continue to pile up
or drag away more bodies with no help
around conserving ammo while keeping the
enemy back became a top priority.
There were no more full
automatic blasts from us.
Although we had been in
contact less than two hours.
It felt like we'd been fighting for
several as the team anxiously awaited for
help from above, the few team
members pitted against the enemy.
NVA seemed ludicrous in terms of survival.
The enormity of the jungle
hit home. Yes. Are you got,
how many rounds did you say you would
bring? We always carried 600 plus per man.
Oh No.
The Vietnamese would carry a load a load
cause they could cause they're small
like 98 pounds.
So I forget what their load when you guys
had 20 round magazines at this point,
right? Correct. 30 we're just a dream.
We thought about and a couple of
guys was far enough to to, to colt
order and they had a mail to him
later. We weren't that smart.
So we had the 20 rounds. But because of
the spring you only put 18 then. Yeah.
And so you're taking this
at some point, probably.
How long into this are you starting to
take point shots instead of Oh yeah.
You just wait until things come
out. You see it and then just one to
find the, I heard the Texas
drawl of spider on the radio,
an f four phantom jet returning from a
bombing run in northern Laos had heard
the beeper and called him. I told
spider, we had a Perry Fryer,
prairie fire emergency spider,
said that he had also called the judge
and the executioner who the judge and the
executioner, they were a
pilots for the one 76 days,
American America Division and they
would have muskets. Okay. And uh,
they had been assigned permanently
to CNC earlier in the year.
Navy built the camp duck and then, um,
they'd been assigned own
camp. Duck was closed down.
They came to food by nasty,
built a barracks that the helicopter
positive stay stand Nero wanted to cruise
them. And
the Marine Corps as Scarface a were
gunships that regularly hung out with us,
saved our bacon. So, um, the,
the judge he had, they
had these old gun shifts,
they could barely get off the ground,
but he had the rocket pods and then, uh,
the executioner was a cook
and he had the, a mini gun,
some awesome call science. Oh
yeah. Going back to the book,
thankfully we had made mirror contact
with spider earlier and he was able to
pinpoint our location in a matter
of minutes. Soon spider was over us.
He told me to pop smoke.
Our Sop was not to say what
color smoke grenade we would use,
assuming the NVA or monitoring our FM
frequency. I popped a yellow smoke.
He said he saw two yellows,
which meant the NVA were monitoring our
frequency and it guessed which color we
would use. We change frequencies
and I popped a violet smoke.
A few minutes later,
the first a one e Skyraider arrived on
target and made a gun run on our eastern
perimeter. His wing man made the
first napalm round on the south side.
Put your heads down. I'm
going to make you sweat.
He said he brought it so close we could
feel the heat from the deadly jelly.
A few seconds later, we smelled burning
flesh. He dived toward us a third time.
The pilot drawed, it's
crispy critter time.
The napalm run was so close we could
feel the air being sucked away from us by
the exploding material. If the
Jelly had landed on a person's skin,
it would continue to burn either until
it burned itself out or as deprived of
air by mud or some other substance.
The spats arrival changed the temple,
the firefight. When the NVA heard the old
World War II plane making another run,
they charged us in D in a desperate
attempt to get as close as they could in
order to avoid the Sky Raiders,
deadly ordinance, the n NVA.
We're getting close to the
belt. That's horrifying.
So for those that don't understand
tactics of that situation,
you've got aircraft overhead.
They're dropping napalm.
So what are the v you think? Oh cool.
That'll make the NVA runaway. No, no.
Actually what they want to do is get
close enough to Americans that they can't
get napalm dropped on them.
And by 68 they had the
tacky down really tight.
They knew when the air per there
that they were safer to closer to us.
And then so they get closer. Hopefully
the wipe us out and saved their own ass.
That's like there's,
I guess there's no higher motivation than
that napalm coming at you if you stay
where you're at. Nasty.
And so therefore, even at
that stage of the game,
we had to go back to four matic couple
of times cause they're charging hard.
Oh yeah. What numbers are we
talking about? No, never knew.
We just stacked them muscle
high. We'd never had, you know,
no time to go do a body count.
You know how that is. Yeah.
You're just busy killing them.
Yeah. I don't want to throw that
out. This all nonchalant like, yeah,
I know how that is. No,
actually we never stacked up body
still high that we lost count.
Uh, going back to the book,
then an Air Force pilot and an
air for fandom arrived on station.
Tell your people the ordinance will
arrive on target before you hear me or the
rounds. The pilot said, I told
the team to put their heads down.
The phenomenon of having bullets tearing
into a target before anyone could hear
the aircraft with delivered
them was unbelievable.
The jungle in front of us was shredded
by the air force gun run within a minute
or two. His wing man
dropped two 500 pound bombs.
The change in aircraft staggered the NVA
for a few moments right then and there.
I thank the Lord for
Uncle Sam's air force.
The judge and the execution are
rolled in right behind the fast mover.
The judges mini gun was real close
to our perimeter. Seconds later,
the execution followed behind him firing
several 2.75 millimeter rockets while
his door gunners blasted away with their
m 60 machine guns because we hadn't
expended any ordinance to our west.
We ran the gunships over the
western edge of our perimeter.
They drew no enemy fire either.
About a half an hour before dusk spider
told us the king bees were on their way.
By that time the judge and the
executioner had refueled reloaded and were
returning a few minutes in front of them.
Everyone in s t Idaho was dangerously
low on ambient ammo grenades and m 79
rounds. So now you've got the the
extract platforms are coming back.
The king bees are coming to get you.
Before the king bees moved
in, an attempt to pick us up.
Spider had the judge and the executioner
make gun runs so close to our perimeter
that we could hear the expended shell
casings from the gun ships and the 60 and
mini guns falling to Earth.
Through all of the excitement
I told walking and that
spider had spotted an area
west of our perimeter where king B might
be able to settle into some elephant
grass for us walking in and
hip pass the word to the team.
And we started moving toward
the area from our location.
We couldn't the elephant grass and I had
assumed we were locked into double or
triple canopy jungle. Again,
the judge and executioner hammered our
eastern flank as we moved toward the
tentative LZ.
So I got x or I if you could explain
spider's position a little bit because
that's pretty,
I think it's pretty unique to Vietnam
of how those guys could be up overhead.
Sort of watching and, and directing.
Yeah, there, um, we called and
copied the code name was Covey, Cov,
e y [inaudible], but they would
afford air controllers basically.
And in the CNC mission, um,
you have an air force pilot at that
time, most of the, uh, cubbies were,
oh two says no two dead. It
pushed pool double engine. And um,
but they always would
have, uh, a prior one,
zero somebody with experience who had
been on a ground who'd be with the air
force pilot. So the pilot would fly,
then he would turn the radios over.
So to spider or whoever the
copywriter was. So that was a,
a slot. So sometimes the guys would be
wounded, they couldn't go to the field,
but they could fly Covey. Got It.
So that when we're on the ground,
we have a situation
that we're dealing with,
then he's able to understand it as
opposed to talking to an air force pilot.
Right.
Who's just used to getting a bomb and
drop it somewhere and talk about a
contingent liabilities that
spin off of a firefight.
And so that was a spider's job.
He was the cubby rider and he and pat
walkers that day were the two cubby riders
that came in and they covers
until they got us out.
Okay,
man. Uh, going back to the
book, sound hip were covered.
Our frantic desperate
drive to the chopper.
After taking 10 minutes to
cover those last 10 yards,
we reached the hovering King Bee, which
is about eight feet above the ground.
Fox set up an impromptu security watch
on the western side of the road, or wash.
A quick check of my ammunition revealed.
I was down to one frag grenade,
one white phosphorous grade, and
two magazines of car, 15 rounds.
If I didn't get extracted that
last frag grenade would be mine.
There was no way in hell
I was going to be a pow,
especially after all the NVA s t,
Idaho and TAC air had
killed. If I had to use it,
I take as many NVA with me as I could.
Okay.
That's a bold statement.
Oh yeah. But that, I just, uh,
by that time we knew about [inaudible]
is what they go on through.
And we had lost a couple of guys and
one of them had escaped and they were,
you know, we're by now we're
hearing the POW stories, right.
So it's bad enough in country,
but for our mission, no,
wasn't going to happen.
I figured it's just to sit and just
try and take as many as we can.
Make it a funnel contact check.
Now you guys eventually get to where
you're loading the, the king bees,
which again, these are Vietnamese pilots.
They're old aircraft, right?
Probably look like they were
held together with duct tape.
Well, they always had oil
and fluids inside. And so
Tom, if you sat in too deep,
you get the fluid on your head. But, uh,
we liked them better than the
UAE because they could take,
they could take more hits and they
had those old B 17 engines up front,
the nine rotary heads and uh, they could
take more hits us while we liked him.
And this a cabin thin, is
that how you say captain 10 10
at some point during the craziness,
I looked up at the pilot of
the King Bee Captain Tin.
He was above all the
madness on the ground,
completely calm and collected while his
aircraft took numerous hits from enemy
rounds.
What made his demeanor all
the more extraordinary was
how it contrasted with our
adrenaline hype, frantic behavior on the
ground. We had been fighting for hours,
we were dirty, we were sweaty,
and we were exhausted and
there sat captain tin,
cool as a rocky mountain breeze,
giving the impression that
it was just another milk run.
It was as though he said, no sweat boys.
I got all day. You just take your time,
the stewardesses, we'll break out the
beverages after you've secured your seats.
Looking at captain tin for a brief moment,
generated a mental image I'd
carried with me forever. Frankly,
I never understood how one man could be
so steady under so much enemy fire and
keep the chopper
hovering.
Can you imagine does day I can't.
Yeah. Yeah, and you go into
a little bit further here.
A day or two after the extraction,
Captain Tin and his crew came in
to fob one's green baret lounge.
I went in and thanked him again in ordered
a couple of rounds of drink for all
the king bee pilots and crew members
speaking through an interpreter.
Capitan said that King Bee, he
flew to extract us from echo four,
had 48 holes in it from an enemy
ordinance sitting at the bar.
Captain Tin appeared to be just as cool
and above the fray of daily life as he
had on seven October 10 said that an
enemy round had torn a baseball sized hole
through one of the rotor blades. I
asked him how he could hover so long.
He told me that when he piloted a
helicopter, he thought only about flying.
Nothing else. No enemy bullets,
weather or anything. Only flying.
If it's my turn to die, I die.
That day wasn't my turn to die.
Amazing man. He's uh, he lives in Arizona
today. Really? He's still alive. Yeah.
Oh, we'll be having him on the podcast.
Hopefully he wants to come on here.
That's awesome. Uh,
and then you had one of
your guys, and this is, uh,
this is like the other end of spectrum.
Like it's hard to maintain when your
guys' Davidson had to talk to you when he
came up and he said, Tilton,
I haven't mentioned that
your nickname was tilt yet.
Where'd you get that nickname?
Pinballs C or you play a pinball machine,
you lose and walk away. Pissed off.
When I lose, I shake the shit out
of, get to see my nickname and neon.
Then I leave. How did the
SF guys know about that?
How'd they learn about it from,
oh, this goes way back. Yeah. As a kid
we used to play pinballs all the time.
Little anger management
issues. Oh indeed. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, so Davidson, he comes up tilt. I
have to tell you something, brother.
I don't think I can do this.
I survived Dak two brother,
but I ain't seen, I never seen
shit like that before in my life.
We were really lucky to survive that
mission. I don't think I can go on.
I hate to desert you brother,
but I think I want off the team.
Okay.
Now I understood that look on
his face from the previous day.
I told Davidson that I respected his
decision and I appreciate his frankness.
I thought it took more
courage to be honest in camp
than to not say anything and
go in the field.
A man unsure in the field could
get other team members hurt.
He re I reiterated that he'd performed
well under fire in echo four he hadn't
run,
he hadn't quit and he had demonstrated
exemplary courage during the entire
mission.
Okay.
As we walked and talked, I put
my hand on the shoulder, James,
you and I had walked in, did something
few men in America will ever do.
We Survived Echo for and all
the NVA could throw at us.
There were six of us against
hundreds of north Vietnamese finest.
We will have, we will
always have a special bond,
something no one can ever take away
from us. Thanks again for your honesty.
I asked him if he wanted me to talk to
the sergeant major or did he want to do
it because he'd only been in campus short
while he asked me if I wouldn't mind
speaking to the sergeant major first
I agreed and asked him what sort of
assignment he preferred.
I don't know brother.
I'll need some time to get my head
straight. Did you have a note in here?
32 years.
32 years later I talked to James
Davidson in New Orleans on the telephone.
One of the things he said was, brother,
I've never been the same
since those two days in Laos.
Oh yeah. And Guinea back to
captain tin for a moment. The uh,
d pulled us out and we land at
Fubu by, I'd climb up the thank,
we say, come on in, I'll get
you a drink. He goes, no,
my family is waiting for
me. Do Holden dinner.
No one even on that extraction that
night, cause it was right at sunset.
And so when we pulled out, it's
one of those beautiful scenes
where it's dark green,
evergreen of the jungle and all these
little sparkling lights that are red with
the green trace was coming
up. If it hadn't been trace,
it was just a beautiful scene.
But then you realize, hey,
that's the NVA still trying to
shoot our dumb ass down. And it was,
but then we flew, he had itself
directly for a few minutes.
We had the sunset because
that sweet sunset,
and it was at that point that sal
looked at me and gave me that look,
this all it was. So we, we cut
the mustard. So he, you know,
cause when I first got into camp, he
looked at me, my came into big spider,
introduce me, and he goes, he's too tall,
his feet are too big and he looks stupid.
It took me five months to get,
he'd get on his good side,
but we finally got there.
An Echo for all you had to do was just
fend off a few hundred NVA together.
Yeah. That's all it took.
And, and so Davidson,
so this was a volunteer to get into the
program and you could add any points.
Say, Hey,
you can quit. Oh yeah, absolutely.
And no dishonor to it. Yeah.
We always preferred because like
with Lynn black in a and chapter six,
when they came up against 10,000,
one of his Americans who was a son of a
general who's just dare to try and get
some metals for himself, um,
never fired one round and anger
and prayed during the entire day,
would his face in the ground, the
Vietnamese were ready to kill him.
So that's kind of thing
that you don't want.
No, no, that's, that's horrible.
Yeah. These, these contacts
that you're getting in, I just,
it's hard for me to get
my head around, you know,
to be out there like alone like that with,
with just really limited
support, you know?
Oh yeah, there are days,
but we had Uncle Sam's air force
and those door gunners are great.
Yeah, absolutely. And we
had Scarface, you know,
from marine corps and we had different
units who are attached to us and we're
just really lucky whenever we call
dailies came and the effect of one a
Scarface, who was Lieutenant
Colonel Robertson,
he pulled us out several
times. He pulls out.
The one time he got his plexiglass
shot out, the bird shot up.
We get us back to Fubu, chewed my
s's. Every time we come to get you.
And he chewed my ass out. We go into
the club. He still chewed my ass out.
I bought him drinks, gone so drunk
he couldn't walk. He had to fly.
He's still two of my SSA kernel.
But you saying you're not
going to come to next ties.
I didn't say that every time you rang
the bell they came, but oh my God,
they could barely don't
ever try to the door guns.
We get down to the helicopter.
They're like the B or d
models as really early you.
He saw this is true at to muskets.
The door goes out to get out and kind
of lift the helicopter as they tried to
get enough power to get off the ground
because they're just so loaded with
ordinance. Then they jump in once
he got moving. Quite a sight.
But they always came and the other thing
is that's weird is they didn't really
have nighttime capability.
None of it like anyone.
So well,
it seems like nowadays night is
no factor for America. Oh, I know.
We would have run over our mother for
one of those dogs. Oh yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. But for you guys,
once the sun went down,
it was hard to get picked up.
It was hard to call for fire.
It seems that way. Oh yeah, no doubt.
And so you were racing the s you were
racing the sun, you were resonate.
You always, yeah, she's a,
she's a key player between the
weather and the sunset. Yeah.
That's the other scary
thing is, I mean, you know,
this is something I usually say
early on, but I haven't said yet.
I'm reading tiny excerpts of this book.
So if you're listening to the podcast,
these are tiny excerpts. This is less
than five, less than 3% of this book.
This book is filled with
this kind of mayhem.
So you have to get the
book to appreciate it all.
I'm just kind of hitting some
of the highlights. But yeah,
the fact that you guys were racing against
the sun going down and how l the sun
goes down. Okay, cool. Where do we go?
Does that mean in modern day seal teams?
For me that means we use a night strobe,
a an an infrared strobe that the enemy
can't see instead of a marking panel.
What does it mean for
you? It means another,
another 12 hours out in the bush cause
you're not getting vict up and just hope
that the uh, the lions that leave you
alone, you know, I mean to tigers,
um, you had this one idea
or you know, your, your,
the group had an idea of dropping
like a big giant daisy cutter,
but a bit bombed like a
2000 pound bomb, right.
In order in areas that
were so packed with,
with vegetation that you couldn't get
in a helicopter in there and say, oh,
we got an idea, we'll
just drop a big bomb.
And those go land in there can get
dropped off in there. And, um, so this,
this one operation where
you're doing that, you're,
you're heading into the jungle,
you're going to one of these things where
you dropped a 2000 pound daisy cutter
bomb, you're repelling, you're the number
one man heading down, right? And you,
you decide that like, hey,
this is an abort situation.
I think you saw some enemy. Oh
yeah. And so you decide, okay,
let's abort this thing and here we're
going to the book. As I looked up,
I was glad to see king who's one of
your team members climbing back into the
king bee.
I got on the radio and told Covey
to abort the mission as we had been
compromised again for
a few fleeting moments.
I'd considered trying to get
the team on the ground. Frankly,
I was sick and tired of getting shot
out of LZs and I wanted to run a mission
instead of going through the gut wrenching
firefight, um, on the lts, which is,
you know, again, I'm
skipping around in this book,
but you would do mission after mission
where you guys would try and land and
you'd get shot off the LZ. Oh yeah. Um,
that'd be the primary, secondary,
and then the, uh, alternative.
You try three insertions, you know,
I'm just gonna I'm just going to,
for the record, if I go one insertion
and I get shout off, I'm coming home.
I'm coming home. [inaudible]
going to go to the secondary Ed.
If I get shot off the secondary,
I'm damn sure not going to the tertiary
and think I'm getting away with it.
I'm going to go back and come
up with a new plan. Well,
but then the king BW run out
of gas. He had to go back. Uh,
so you're there.
Then I saw the helmet of an NVA
soldier heading toward the bombed area.
He was approaching from the area where
I heard the first voice from the jungle
area in front of the helicopter,
which was up the hill from
where I was on the ground.
As soon as I saw my open
fire with my car, 15,
suddenly the king be swerved
away, leaving me on the ground.
Suddenly it was eerily
quiet. Then it hit me.
I was standing in the middle of a smoking
LZ in the middle of Laos and I was
alone. All of a sudden I
felt small, very small.
The trees that had survived
the bomb blast were tall.
The jungle surrounding the LZ was
both impressive and formidable and not
somewhere I wanted to travel by myself.
I tried to raise Covey on the radio.
There was no answer from Watkins,
even though I was the American
team leader on s t Idaho.
I insist on carrying the radio because
I wanted to be the person calling air
strikes around my team.
The Vietnamese kept us alive in the
field and I felt my end of surviving the
jungle warfare was to direct tactically
or strikes and helicopter gunships to
the enemy. So the king B comes back.
So you're there, the king B comes
back, captain two ong drafts a row,
drops a rope down to you for you to clip
into cause it's I guess too tight for
it to land or it doesn't wanna land
cause it's gonna take a bunch of time and
energy. So they just throw you
a rope yet they can't land.
Cause there are too many tree stumps.
They didn't cut everything down.
And then at that time we were just uh,
refining the tactic of
using rope extractions.
So for anyone that's listening right now,
when you're refining tactics, try
and do it on training operations.
Well we did, we trained with this.
We knew we had dug to 50 foot rope,
a sandbag to it,
and then it had a d ring on
the end and be 150 foot rope.
And so they had to have a sandbag.
So we'd get through the jungle,
get to the ground to you. And
we had developed other tactics,
but you had a d ring on your chest.
Well, you're going to get to that. Yeah.
Yeah. So here we go. I saw no NVA,
but the weapon that was being fired
had the unmistakable bark. Renee 47.
I fired another m 79
round in that direction.
That rounds explosion must've startled
capping Tuong because he jerked the king
be upward yanking me off the ground
before I could slip the d ring on my left
shoulder around the rope.
That shoulder d-ring was critical
for staying in the Swiss seat.
We had heard horror stories about the
body desecration and the NVA had performed
on SOG, men, and I didn't
want that happening to me.
As Toowong lifted me into the
air, I opened fire with my car,
15 on what appeared to be a flash
coming from the hilltop area.
So you're getting hoisted up by the
helicopter while you're returning fire and
slipping out of your deep ring. It
didn't quite get hooked in that.
As we got a little higher up, I was
ricocheting off the trees. I was,
I was a human pinball for a few
minutes there. Tilt. There we go.
Uh, then I became scared. So then
you decided to become scared. Okay,
that's fine. I still
hadn't hooked my shoulder.
D-Ring and someone fired
a few green tracers out.
As captain Toowong started to
pull out of the target area.
As he started gaining speed,
I ricocheted off a few trees
before I cleared the jungle.
Having sat in the king bees copilot seat,
I understood why he pulled away from
the LZ before I had cleared the trees.
If the chopper gets shot down,
the mission turns into an operational
nightmare while potentially injuring or
killing the crew and the [inaudible]
team members aboard the ship.
I wasn't angry with him
how he came back from me.
I would have been stranded down here
for at least two more hours before other
choppers with ropes could have been
able to extract me if he hadn't,
but being dragged through the trees hurt.
I was angry at myself for not getting the
damn d-ring hooked before I lifted off
the ground. My arms were getting
very sore. As I went to switch arms,
I was struck by some sort of air pocket
and suddenly I was upside down at 5,000
feet.
My only physical link to life was the
d ring hooked into my rope seat and the
hundred and 50 foot piece of
rope hanging from the helicopter.
I twisted my body to
look up at king again.
Thank God he was still
hanging out the door.
I signaled to get the chopper to
land. As I was giving king signs,
I felt the rope slipping down my
FYS to my knees. At the same time,
my web gear was sliding from
my hips over my stomach,
toward my neck and a matter of moments.
The Swiss seat was at my knees.
The only way I stopped it from moving
further was by spreading my legs.
I felt really stupid
after all the training.
This was going to be a dumb way to
die. As the ropes slid across my feet,
I knew I was moments away from passing
out and there was no way I could keep my
legs spread. Just before the end,
several brief scenes from my life
flashed through my mind. Dolores,
my kindergarten sweetheart.
Why did she move to California?
I saw my dad's new 1949 Chevrolet milk
truck with its dark evergreen paint with
the white side panels and
rich gold leaf letters,
my red wagon from Childhood
High School Football Games,
and to add insult to injury, I saw
the front page article in my hometown,
part paper about my death.
The story was below the fold
because stories about local
boys dying and nom were
now commonplace.
That angered me because my family
would never know where I really died.
On the other hand, I didn't want
them to know how I really died.
Just as I started to pass out, I
felt the ropes slip off my feet.
My body went limp.
I vaguely remember hitting the elephant
grass before landing hard on my back on
the ground. I had fallen only or 20 feet.
The Ella elephant grass cushion the fall.
I hadn't realized that Captain Twang
had the aircraft descending during those
last frantic moments.
Oh yeah. Have those legs spread
like a New York City Hooker.
Yeah, that's a, that's a nightmare.
Yeah. King came and picked me up
and threw me in the, in the chopper,
left all my gear there, so
my car 15 and my sod knife,
which now would be a highly treasured
item. Still only us [inaudible].
Oh yeah. He just pulled to open a web
gear and had to get the thing off my neck.
The rucksack, the web gear
though just choked me out.
He pulled it off and just picked me up
and threw me in the helicopter and there
I was really happy to feel my head
bounce off that metal floor. It hurt,
but it a happy hurt.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah. Again,
if you have to get this book,
cause that's, I'm, I'm trying
to pick like some good stories,
but these are just the
kind of ridiculous, uh,
things that are going on just another
day and a saw just another day in SOG
getting hung upside down. 5,000 feet
above enemy territory by a d ring.
Um, another one here,
you guys got some bad weather,
you're got no support overhead.
That's another thing people
need to understand is when you,
because of where you guys were located
at a pretty good distance away from the
bases, if there was no aircraft overhead,
then you wouldn't be able to
communicate with anyone because they,
you'd lose line of sight. Did
you guys carry ever Curie,
HF radios to try and make long distance?
We had VHS for UHF. He
had to earn 10 was that,
and but um, at nights
during the day to Rizza,
there was always an airborne
command aircraft up.
So at the daytime was Hillsboro code.
At night it was moonbeam. So they would
check in with us on our frequency.
So you would, no matter what, you'd have
some level of comps. Okay, that's good.
So because of the,
uh, we knew the NVA, a RDF radio
direction finder was really good.
There were, there were sharp on that. So
when they would check in with us again,
if we just
click, click [inaudible] no discussion.
And for those of you that don't know that,
that's direct radio direction finding.
So if you sit there and talk on the
radio for a long period of time,
the enemy can actually capture
those, those transmissions.
They try and get when they use multiple
stations and they can tell what
direction they're coming from and they
can triangulate where you're at and they
can come and get you. So for
this particular one, you guys,
or the weather's bad,
so you don't have any,
you don't have any actual
direct support overhead. The,
the NVA had been chasing,
this is the one where you got,
you tried to set up an ambush and
then they told you don't do it.
I know we had to add was
set up. We had been at,
but then they told you you
don't the ambush, right,
don't execute it because we were had
visions of we get the Po dubby could the
nut day if you,
we kept a live p o w five day
rnr anywhere in the world,
a hundred dollars bonus. I was like, man,
we're talking about where the
and plans, Hawaii or Australia.
We hadn't quite decided and as spider
came back over and I gave them the cobe,
we got appealed.
W we'll be back at the primary LZ
in one hour and that's what he said.
Don't move. But you hadn't initiated,
you didn't have the [inaudible] yet.
You were waiting. Oh yeah, they're
walking up and down to chill.
It was just a matter of time
before you were going to,
well we spring your ambush and this is
one of those deals where we violated all
the rules of recon. Normally we go
10 and 10 walk, 10 minutes, pause,
tend to hear the jungle, let the
jungle see how it's gone. Wellness one,
because we've had so much
trouble trying to get in.
They had a slash and burn areas. There
were underneath the jungle canopy.
I divided the team. We had an eight
man team this time before in each side.
And I said, we're going to go up
this hill until we get to an area,
to a trail or whatever. And we didn't
stop. We went really hard. Maybe 20, 30,
40 minutes. I forget now.
We came up to the big trail,
we crossed it one at a
time, covered our tracks,
got things set up south prep. The wiretap
had a perfect damn voice. You know,
we had trained, uh, Lynn
Black had developed the, uh,
the, uh,
ambush kill zone so that we'd have
clay Morris that would go across,
but in a center dubious six foot
area that there'd be no shrapnel.
But we had, he, he practiced
on himself as C four.
So he finally figured out at the certain
length what a stick a c four was.
We in knock yourself out,
but he did literally, I know
this is another, oh yeah.
So anyway, that's our input
book. But we had it all set up.
So we had the c four to
knock out one person,
Morris to kill everybody else with sides
perimeters and one in the rear just in
case he came down to mountain on us
and their diddy bopped in up and down a
trail. We could, we could have had
officers there walking down to trail.
Nobody's that upset because
we had gone so far, so fast,
violating all of our rules that the pupil
up to hill didn't know what was going
on down the hill. And then spider
says don't move. I was like,
that's when things got really
ugly. And, and when he,
what was the reason why he told you
guys don't do it because the weather was
moving in. Oh yeah.
Because we'd only been in the ground
two or three hours and whether sock did,
he's at 10,000 feet. I can't even
see the mountain, let alone CNL z.
So he's saying, look, we're not going
to be to get you out of there right now.
Just don't do whatever you're going to
do and, and, and Oh yeah, break contact.
Get away. Yeah. So you guys
are kind of kind of on the run,
you gotta start moving out of there.
Right. And so about that time up the hill,
we hear the tanks and other
trucks starting up their
engines and all of a sudden
the activity on the goes
from casual to frantic.
Now everybody's two or three
guys, they all got their eks.
What do you think clued him in that,
that you were there while they heard
come in. By then we could hear the dogs.
They have some dogs that were deaf back
on Elz so they had started looking for
us officially. So when you
hear dogs, tanks, trucks,
and a bunch of people with AK 47
yeah. How do you feel about that?
Um, the pucker factor is minus
zero. It really is. It's like,
oh my God.
And you know that you've got no form of
extraction. Correct. The weird thing is,
I guess, and, and having worked in the
jungle a little bit, you know, I've,
I spent some time in the jungle in
South American, that's Southeast Asia.
Like I will say this, the jungle is huge,
right? Yeah. And you could see where,
okay, I can get, I can make
myself scarce at least. Oh yeah.
Until you remember they got
trackers right. And they got dogs,
lots of them.
So you're in that situation here.
Yeah, another Thursday night.
But we did get the wiretap though.
Sal HUD, Rhonda Rock once for an hour.
So once you won, you guys had to take
the tape recorder with you though.
Oh yeah. We carried the
little, um, you know,
you think about a traditional
early old cassette recorder,
so it had like two or four the chip of
a Ed d batteries in and then we had the
um,
microphone that had a little plugging
in and then sal would run up the tree or
fly up the telephone pole that his case.
He had gone up when he came back
down and put mud on the whole thing.
So anybody going by on a trail looked
at the pole, they wouldn't see it.
And so we ran it for over an hour.
We had run that wire tap and
it flipped the cassette over,
cause that was state of the
art at the time. Your sets.
All right. So yes, we want to break
this up down. Now you guys are moving,
pull back all to clay Morris to see
for which direction did you head,
um,
did you go away from where you inserted
or did you go back to where you were?
Um, we went, no, we went away from it. Um,
if I'm facing Elz we
went to our left. Got It.
And we went and we had to go
way across that big trail again.
But this time we had to cross it in
between enemy come up and down the truck.
It went past us and so took us a while
to get back across the big trail.
Cause this trail, again,
this is layoffs by the way.
This is t Minh trail, the Coachee,
Montreal spiders that even
when he could see the jungle,
he couldn't see that road.
And the road was big enough.
You could drive tanks down
in side-by-side. It's huge.
It would be the equivalent
of a highway 78. Okay.
Or 50 to two lanes. So tank side by side,
but it's conveniently covered by
the covered by the judge vegetation.
So it took us a while to get across
the road. Then we went to the left,
then we finally came
to a little stream bed and went up
that stream because now it's dark,
but now we hear more dogs.
The activity on the trail,
another couple of trucks go by and all
this noise we noted looking at eventually
your hold up in your, your you, you stop.
Right and an a on a way up
that stream we put out pepper.
We put out a mace to throw off the dogs,
locked the doors and we had our team
go up and down these little cars.
It was about 10 foot tall bank.
We're in this little creek or stream,
had water in it and so we
was trying to lose the dogs.
We knew to come in at night and now it's
dark and we contin up that stream for
awhile. Call.
Wanted to get as far away from them as
we could because salad climbed a tree and
said their common. He pointed out,
he said he told Hep there were
hundreds of them coming with lights.
They all had lanterns and
the dogs were getting closer,
sweet canteen up, death's dream
for another hour or two at night,
doing still going out and
putting down a amazed me finest.
We're not to the bank on the
right, set up our Ron for tonight,
rest overnight and I'm facing the bank
and the other seven guys are around and
so again, we hear the
dogs, the people, so we,
they're in the rof maybe
two or three hours.
Two guys come up the the up the stream
with a lantern burning brightly.
They pass,
this lantern goes out and they come
back as they come pack hep costs
and then they stopped and I think
that's where you're going next.
Well yeah, that's here. Here it is.
One of the NVA and the creek started
crawling up the embankment toward me.
I was still facing the creek.
The NVA soldier was good.
He only moved when the wind
stirred the trees for a moment.
My faults drifted to summer camp in New
Hampshire years earlier when we played
capture the flag on those
clear summer nights.
My favorite trick was to use the woods
to get as close to the flag as possible.
Now,
my mind was racing a hundred miles per
hour and I realized I was the flag and he
was closing in.
He was too close for me to tell
anyone on my team. The jungle.
That night seemed deadly quiet,
except of course when the wind stirred
as the NVA soldier crawled closer,
I remembered thinking that my heart was
beating so damn loud that hoe men could
hear it in Hanoi.
I flashed back to my childhood when we
used to play hide and go seek on West
Paul Avenue in Trenton, New Jersey.
One of my favorite hiding places was
behind the hedges and Mr and Mrs Amigos,
Front Yard.
I remember worrying that Teddy's a Broski
or John Wayne Austin or worse Barbara
Poynton would find me because they
could hear my heart beating so loud.
I tried to comfort myself by thinking
that because I had not been running in
recent hours, my heartbeat
shouldn't be too loud. Yet.
My heart sounded like a kettle drum
during Beethoven's ninth no matter the NVA
soldier kept moving up the embankment.
I was very impressed with his
stealth.
I could barely hear him than it
happened during one windy moment.
I heard movement very close to
me. It was only a slight sound,
but a sound. Nonetheless,
before the wind stopped,
the NVA soldier touch the soul of my size.
10 of our army issue, jungle boot.
I heard a slight gasp of surprise
from him. At that moment.
I had a death grip on my car. 15
I had it on single shot a car,
15 on full automatic sound's
much different from the
bark of an AK 47 on full
automatic. If I had to shoot it would
be single shots for a millisecond.
I wondered if my left foot was far enough
to the left so that when I fired it,
I wouldn't shoot myself. Time stood still.
My pucker factor was minus zero.
After a few of the longest seconds
of my life, the wind stirred,
but there was no movement. He remained
still after what seemed like an eternity.
The wind stirred again and I heard
the NVA moved backwards just slightly.
He was so cool. I knew he was facing me.
I wondered why I couldn't hear his heart.
The jungle around us remained pitch black
as my twilight zone moment. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's uh, that's,
that's craziness. And
you think he was, um,
you think he just decided like this,
this guy's probably got the
drop on me and I want to live.
What do you think he decided?
I believe so because if there had
been any other movement at all,
okay.
Then he would've been on the receiving
end of the five, five, six [inaudible].
So he did, he did. He made a tactical
decision to live. Yeah. Thank God. Yeah.
Cause they know.
Then obviously once you started shooting
the gay gigs up and you would have
been,
people would be on your trail clothes and
had it happen to me I thought was if I
just did one single shop,
could the muscle flash would light up
where he was and then I was hoping to,
would take no more than a second shot
to finish him off so that the jungle,
they would hear gunshots but they
weren't, wouldn't be quite sure
where was this?
And people that haven't spent time
out in the woods or out in the jungle,
it can get completely pitch black in
the jungle. Is that what this was?
Was this just like complete, like he's,
you could barely even could you
see his face at all? Nothing.
I mean he probably knew he was there.
You sit there and you could feel your
hand in front of your nose when you shake
it, move it back and forth. You
can feel the breeze from your hand,
but you can't see it. Yeah. So for
those of you that haven't been in this,
it's when you get up at nighttime and
then it's a cloudy night and then you're
in triple canopy jungle.
There is no light,
non can't see anything and
that's what this situation is.
Absolutely.
Well luckily you,
you got out of that and then you guys
continue on going back to the book.
By nine o'clock we had
located the LZ and secured it.
The clear area had several feet of grass
on it and the ground was at an angle
because it was on the
side of mountain. Again,
we heard dogs, our
tactical scenario stunk.
We are in a relatively open area on a
hillside with minimal cover and the NBA
had the high ground times
seem to be our worst enemy.
Although having limited air, air resources
didn't improve our mood. Finally,
the other team was extracted without
taking firs further casualties and spider
was overhead taking ground
fire from the north of the LZ.
He told the trustee and reliable marine
corps you h one B gunships with the
radio call sign.
Scarface were seconds away as we
heard the chopper's approaching us.
One of the toe poppers that Salud
Sun had planted, exploded, exploded.
So you guys were doing that too. You
guys don't set booby traps on them,
on the enemy and set
claymores on them, right?
Which would really piss
them off. Oh yeah. Hey,
try to ruin their parade. Yeah, we knew
the NVA were going to be hopping mad.
Now that's a gentle way of putting it.
Spider was able to vector the Scarface
gun shipped to our location quickly.
There was no time for orientations.
We popped smoke and seconds later,
the first Scarface chopper
roared in the jungle north of us,
or ruptured with small arms fire.
The second Scarface chopper
roared in so close it.
I could see the facial
expressions on the door gunners.
He blasted the area north of our LZ with
his m 60 machine gun. Both Scarface,
both Scarface aircraft took several hits.
When the sky Raiders made their passes.
They also took hits from small arms
fire that sounded like AK 47 during the
second gun run, sal blew a claim
or in the face of an NVA scout.
Sal then flew a second claim. Warn,
returned to the LZ reporting more NVA
troops right behind him. And you guys,
this is another interesting sop. We
would do this to carry claymores.
I didn't do that. I, Oh, let me rephrase
that. We got trained to do this,
you know, you know
jungle situation, right?
You guys would make claymores with like
five second and ten second fuses on
them, right? Boom. Put 'em down, pull
the fuse so you run. Yeah, and run.
I never used one of those and I'm
very thankful that I did not. Yeah.
Uh, yeah.
Apparently the combination of air
assets and our 40 millimeter barrage has
slowed the NVA troops long enough for
the extraction ships to come to the LZ.
Spider told me that the a hundred first
airborne division was going to extract
us.
The Marine Corps gunships would make one
more gun run and for the first time s t
Idaho slicks from the a hundred first
airborne division would follow right
behind them and get as
close to the LZ as possible.
We were used to the King B's and knew
most of the pilots on a first name basis.
The a hundred first pilots were good too.
But because this was our first time
with a a hundred first airborne division
slicks,
I told Sean King that they had to be the
first people to approach the ship and
that they had to alert the young door
gunners that fought that five of our men
were Vietnamese. That's a crazy
thing to think about. Oh, absolutely.
So you got the head. We had
horrible results when they would,
when you weren't careful.
And again, you know, young
door gunners for sure coming to country
and if they're not briefed properly, uh,
cause our guys dressed irregularly, they
had, not that they will look like NVA,
but they're, they weren't Americans.
We've had team members that lost
Vietnamese anyway. Yeah. Tragically
we, we, uh, when Roger Hayden was on, he
told a story of the same thing he had.
They had, they had, uh,
Vietnamese scouts and they were doing
a hammer and anvil operation with a
platoon they hadn't worked with
before that was new in country.
And there was some mix up puts
on the insertion and you know,
just some minor mistakes that
compounded. And anyways, these guys, the,
the Advil portion was waiting and the
first guys that came out of the tree line
were there Vietnamese scouts. Yeah.
And they got, they got lit up.
Um, you know, we were in,
in, when I was in Ramadi,
we, I, you know,
you see like pictures of seals with like
beards and all that and look at cool
like w everyone shaved and everyone,
we weren't regular uniforms with what
the army and what the Marine Corps war.
Why? Because that exact reason, you know,
you swing around a corner and you've got
a 19 year old on a 50 cal and he sees
some guy with a beard and a gun.
There's a chance you're getting shot.
Whereas an American, you know, cause
cause the jihadists would have beards,
right. And in Ramadi,
we just didn't [inaudible] everything we
could do to identify ourselves as good
guys did. And
do you hottest could have everything
from [inaudible] for spar beans to a case
you didn't know what they'd be carrying.
And they also want least we knew
our guys had a case or does.
Yeah. Well, the other thing was they were,
they wore paramilitary outfits
because they wore cammies,
they wore body armor sometime. They
wore helmets sometimes. So yeah,
that's amazing that you guys
that and also you had the,
you had the Cognizant's to
say, Hey, wait a second,
we've never worked with
these helicopters before.
Get out there and tell them we've got
some Vietnamese folks coming their way.
Right.
With AK 40 sevens. Yeah.
They were pissed because when king
went down for the first chopper,
nobody else followed and I said,
you make sure you tell them.
Then you give me the greenlight
devil, a little people.
And then Bubba and I got on the second
extract and there's two of the things on
that mission. Yeah. King
had experimental pump,
m 79 which she carried. It
helped five rounds and we,
we thought we'd try it once, but
he carried it for five date. Well,
the whole five days we were on the
ground and so at that LZ it worked and
imagine five m 79 rails
go off the 40 millimeters.
Then also one night was the night
that the Russians flew over us.
And did a resupply and we were begging
for moon beam to show up because somebody
on a Russian ass,
but the whole side of mountain ended up
as a weirdest damn thing we ever saw.
So that was like a signaling device for
it. That was signaling devices that the,
that the Vietnamese were using to have
the Russians drop the resupply in there.
They were
doing resupplies to the Vietnamese.
What language did you speak? Uh,
my foreign language is English.
So they pushed this through and they
weighed the way the language required
because by 68, they knew we had
SF had a strong interpreter corps.
Got It. Like Ma, like Hap,
he spoke four languages.
He had been educated in France and he
cracked up my English and he was a smart
ass on top of it. A little fucker.
But he was already a little guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Awesome. Uh,
going back to the book, the extraction
was slick and quick win. Um,
as we pulled out of the automatic
l, as we pulled out of the LZ,
the slick took several hits.
Three of us returned full
automatic fire from our car.
Fifteens I threw a white phosphorus
grenade as the area north of the LZ,
lit up with dozens of muzzle
flashes from AK 47 and [inaudible].
The green traces from the
AK 47 is appeared as though
they were coming between
my legs. I was told later that as
our slick pulled out of the LZ,
the iscar phase gunships laid
down a full fuselage fuselage of,
of suppressing fire.
The lead marine aircraft piloted
by Lieutenant Colonel Robinson,
had the plexiglass windshield blown
out of the aircraft. In addition,
his chopper and the second gunship
had taken more than a dozen hits.
And yeah, that's, that's, that's, that's
the uh, colonel that you were saying,
yes, he was riding you and riding you.
And by the way, you tell it the book,
colonel, does this mean the next time
we're in trouble, we call for Scarface.
You won't respond to the bell. Hell No.
Robinson responded. I never said that.
It just pisses me off when
my aircraft gets shot up.
Parts are hard to come by
and I'd rather be flying
fearless. And
you know you continue on
here. I went back to my room,
so this is after that crazy operation.
You barely make it out for the
hundredth time that you've you,
you dance in death's face.
I went back to my room and picked up a
news magazine with a picture on the front
page about the biggest latest anti
war protests, state side, insane.
Who side were they on?
They hadn't seen Charlie like
s t Idaho had they never,
they never asked Sao hip and other
Vietnamese men on my team what they felt
about the war.
What a day as three refuse to pull us
out when we were ready for extraction.
Then as three question my integrity,
despite the fact that we were only
minutes away from fighting NVA in close
quarters battle had not Scarface.
The [inaudible] and the a hundred first
airborne slicks defended us from the sky
and there are people back in the states
protesting this war. I shook my head,
dropped my rucksack and web gear,
picked up a small ammo belt,
holding several magazines of five, five,
six ammo and went to the
s three to get a jeep.
The dentist was only a
short drive up the road,
but I kept my trusty car 15 nearby.
Anyway, I went to the dentist,
got my tooth pulled and drew
knew and PRC 25 batteries.
Okay.
And th the reason I read all that is to
read this line right here. The next day,
the next day s D Idaho
got shot out of five LZs
yeah, once in the morning
and once in the afternoon.
And by that time when we got
inserted on that Missionar uh,
we had gone a couple of days, the same
thing in the morning gets shot out.
And on one of those
missions on the primary L Z,
when a King p was going in south,
saw a wire across the LZ.
Now how does sal even see a wire in
a helicopter? When we're going in?
He saw it. He told the
door gunner. Fortunately,
the Vietnamese thing was quick and they
were able to swerve away and a one came
in and hit that with a 500 pound bomb.
They knew we were coming
and we had been compromised.
We never realized how seriously we'd
been compromised and that was proof,
hard proof and where our guys are.
So Tara switched a lot of
Vietnamese around [inaudible]
you, so your, your guys were, some of
your Vietnamese were getting burned out.
Oh sure.
Cause you know you, you do that
long flight, go out through the LG,
then you go in and get shot out, shot
out, shot out, fly back, get lunch,
get a new target. Sometimes they just say,
here's your next target cubby
would know where it would be.
We wouldn't even have any kind
of background or anything on it.
Just they wanted to get a team on the
ground, go back and then we did it again.
Bam, Bam, Bam.
And sometimes we u n so you're
Vietnamese sometimes say, all right,
I've had enough of the school. Is your
main, who is your main outlet guy?
South by counterpart. He was
the assistant team leader.
He is the Vietnamese team leader.
And who was the other American
that would be with you? Uh,
at that point in time
was Bubba John's shore.
He came on the team in a November where
I became to one zero at the end of
October. And these guys were all freaked
out too. Cause you were like young.
Oh yeah. And what were you, uh,
what was your rank at that time?
Well, by then I'd been promoted to e
four cause I remember on that promoted,
yeah,
he deuce in camp with the built for
e eight or a nine on a recon team.
So spider probably got me
promoted back to PFC said,
now roll up your sleeves so people think
you're a sergeant. We don't want the,
no, you're just a dumb ass PFC
instead of by October
we able to add a Spec for, and then, uh,
when Jim wanted off the
team, which we respected.
And to this day I respected it. Never,
I'll never say a word against them
on that. Um, then Bubba came on.
So in November, that's when
Babou uh, he was the a one one.
And then on that one
mission king came along.
I just felt funny about I want a little
extra firepower and he wanted to try
that. Uh, that pump and 79 yeah. Yeah.
Why not just going off on a
mission to test that then? Yeah,
we had that a, they sent us some
thermobaric grenades for the m 79.
Oh really? Yeah. And,
and then they called a week later and
said, hey, did you guys get a Cha?
It was actually leaf,
I think life dumped it up like an entire
load out of them on one operation.
And anyways, they, they call
back, they say, hey, did you guys,
we're wondering if you
get a chance to use those.
They're motto Thera Boma grenade yet.
Like where we use the mall, send more,
here's the feedback. Do not wait.
Well, yeah. And also as it, speaking of
that, as, as one of our side missions,
we always carried eldest
son or Italian green,
which would be enemy ordinance.
Dr Took slowed in her face.
So when we would go along a trail like
wood, that pictorial, we crossed it.
We'd go down and dump a little
the Ammo, so if anybody was CDMO,
they'd pick it up and then
if we ever came across cache,
which only happened a few times, we
would put the bad ammo in their cache,
so they use it for psyops. Then
it would blow up on her face.
I was a good psyops thing
when they were, there was,
there was another mission where you
talk about where they'd killed the
Americans, but they let the, Oh,
you have the Vietnamese girl
that was there January 1st 69
all right. Speaking of holiday
season, here's Christmas Day 1968
you're inserted into like some
really tall elephant grass.
There's NVA around you. Going back to
the book due to the elephant grass,
both in terms of the noise we
were making and how muffled,
how it muffled our other sounds,
we couldn't tell exactly how many
NVA were moving or if they were,
even NVA black said, I smell smoke.
Either our hand grenades or
the NVA has started fires.
Okay.
Things are really heating up on the
LZ. Literally, I radioed spider.
I told them we were surrounded and had
fires on two sides of our perimeter.
I told him that if the king
bees didn't get in here asap,
s t Idaho would be engaged in
fighting fires as well as fire fights.
Were you really making these punny
jokes in the middle of these situations?
Sometimes you have to laugh
to keep from crying. Uh,
they're starting more fires.
Bubba said by now the noise from
the fire forces to raise our voices.
When we were talking to each other,
the smoke was getting thicker.
I began to sweat.
We threw a few more hand-grenades down
the hill to force the NVA to keep their
heads down the southern fire.
So just so everyone understands,
this is what's actually happening. You're
in elephant grass, dry elephant grass,
and it's burning on multiple
sides of your position,
which is 12 to 15 feet
tall. The elephant grass.
So your visibility is like five
feet. Three feet. Yeah. Minimal.
And it's filled with smoke. Yeah.
And getting worse. However we wish
you a merry Christmas. Yeah.
The southern fire's intensity grew by
the second and continued to move up the
slope towards us and around to the east.
There was fire or fires to
the north and northeast,
but they weren't heading toward Estee,
Idaho with the speed of the southern
flames. By now, the smoke was so thick,
I had my green cravat over my
face and pulled up over my nose,
burning embers from the south,
kicked up and flew over our
small jaggedy perimeter,
dumping ashes sot and small burning sparks
on the elephant grass and on us only
hip and Twan wore hats.
Several of US soaked our hair.
Black told me that the NVA weren't far
behind the flames to wanted report and
seeing images of short distance behind
the flames to the south and southeast.
Captain Twang knew exactly where we were.
As he brought the age 34
down the canyon toward us.
Seconds became ours.
My vision was clearer than ever and
I was a co cutely aware of the smoke,
fire popping sounds and enemy gunfire.
I stood on the western edge of the
perimeter waving a colored panel skyward,
trying to catch the pilots. I, the age
34 continued its slow motion descent.
All I saw was the bottom of the chopper
with the front of the strut sticking out
to the right and left coming down like
a giant praying mantis. The rotor wash,
when the king bee began to hit us.
Finally the chopper's nose turned slightly
to the left and I could see captain
twang seeing his face,
seeing him sitting in there.
So commonly in the pilot seat
made my confidence surge.
We would survive. And then
you guys, you guys, you know,
get, get around, get it under control.
Well under control as you can and you
start boarding the tropper chopper as the
last man board of the chopper, I signal
to the door gunner to exit the area.
As I sat in the door, I sat in the doors,
Twang lifted the king be straight up
for several feet before heading south.
As we pulled away from the knoll
fire, swept up the hill and Gulf.
The area where we had been
standing moments earlier.
Oh yeah.
Every Christmas I, Paula's
Captain Twang roared down the canyon.
We had chugged only a short while ago.
I radioed spider and gave
him a team. Okay. Once again,
s t Idaho entered that
magical post-mission moment.
The adrenaline was still flowing.
We had survived another target.
Every breath of air was sweeter.
Yeah.
There was no thought of Christmas
mom or holiday presence.
Our gift was to be alive
that Christmas 1968 would haunt me
sporadically for more than 25 years.
After a while, I was able
to stop sitting upright,
sweating with fear when
the nightmares hit.
It's been almost 10 years
since I had that dream.
But every Christmas
nightmares are not. I always
take a moment to think of
captain twangs courage.
No sweat can bs. Never rest.
Yeah. So that was, uh, this is, that's,
that's just a crazy
situation. Oh yeah. Close.
And then this is like on Thanksgiving
was when we had the mission down south
where our six mayor recon team,
the credal tells us you have to find
three missing NBA divisions to first the
third and the seventh. We found them.
How'd that work out for you? Uh,
it was pretty intense. We use,
we use more than one of those five second
fuses as the holding back. Yeah. Yeah.
Just that again, that's,
that's why you need to buy
this book and read this book.
If you want to hear about the eight man
spike team versus a division on that day
was three, three divisions. For
those of you that don't academy this,
that's 30 30,000 men roughly. And yeah,
that's where those, those um, five
second few of those five second fuses.
Just so everybody
understands what that means.
You're trying to escape the enemy.
You have a little thing
called the claymore mine.
It's like the size of a book,
maybe a little bit bigger and it's got
a bunch of ball-bearings on one side,
the 500 5,550 ball-bearings
on one side that are,
that spray out when,
when this thing explodes.
And those are so like wound people. How
many of those things did you guys carry?
Um, every,
everybody had one on a team and then
the one one or least carry two or three.
So you guys had lawless C4 yeah, at
least. And so what these guys would do,
so you can use them for a bunch of
different reasons. And one of the,
one of the things that you guys did
a lot with them, and this is again,
these are things that I was trained in
when I was first got the seal teams aid
too. Okay. When you set up a,
when you're going to sleep at night or
you're going to set up a a rest overnight
position, you're going
to put out claymores.
And that way if you get attacked
in the middle of the night, boom,
you can light off the claymores and you
a can get some fire superiority or at
least shocked the enemy
or do some damage to them.
So you guys did that all the time,
but then you made these little five-second
fuses knowing that if you're running
away, you can just put
this thing up, you know,
put it in the ground real quick or
put it up against the tree pull. Yeah.
You always want to have it up against
the tree or something to take the back,
pull it back.
Even when you put it in and you've got
the last four seconds before it explodes,
you're running. You could still,
you want to make sure that you got a
little protected on the black blast.
We used to detonate those things that are
completely unsafe distance behind him.
I like, I look back now and I'm thinking,
what were we doing? WTF Times two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Uh, it's like
we play the game. Let's find out.
Are you relate the limb blocks.
So now on this thing. Yeah. Yeah.
So you started to tell
that story a little bit.
For those of you who didn't catch
the whole story, the story Lynn Black
was trying to figure out what it
would take to knock somebody out with
[inaudible]. So see for as six
feet. Yeah. C Four just explodes.
There's no shrapnel in it. You can put
shrapnel in it, but you don't have to.
So it's just, it's just a big concussion.
So Lynn Black was trying to figure out
how much c four it would take so we can
stun a guy so we can grab
them so we can get a pow.
So that we can get a five day
liberty anywhere in the world,
anywhere and $100 cash. And
so he figured, so the way he,
the way he experimented with this
was by doing it to himself. Yeah.
Just standing around at the range and
blastic himself with heavier and heavier
weight until he got knocked out. And
when he finally succeeded, he, uh,
his hearing was bad for a few days.
Yeah. His hair was all. So, you know,
I try this with the, I don't
know if this in the seal teams,
that would've been weird to use the new
guy for that we would use the new guy
like, okay, let's see
if this works. I'll do,
let's when the s when the a stun
guns, the tasers first came in,
it wasn't fun to be a new guy because
we had to see how those things work.
Right. So we, uh, we used
to experiment with that.
So, um, yeah, those,
that story is just crazy.
And you and you looking down
and seeing the firing Gulf,
the place that you just got picked.
Oh yeah. Instantly. Sure.
Is this like one of those moments
in time? It's the same thing.
Like on Thanksgiving
Day, we got distracted.
Deer were coming out of the jungle
running at port arms and so they would be
tried to come down. So
me in the door gunner,
which is Lily's stopped
him in to try like one.
Those cartoons you see on the TV you
would have guys running and stops.
He gets Janke.
They would just push them right back
in the jungle before he even fell down.
And that was just, um, yeah, you
just, you don't forget those things.
They stick with you.
The next chapter is called
a happy new year. Oh hmm.
Uh, the day after Christmas,
the s three brass asked s t Idaho
to run another m a target and Laos,
I respectfully declined citing
fatigue and general weariness.
I didn't tell the brass that I had
a funny feeling about the target.
I felt apprehensive for some reason.
Okay.
Back at fob one around 1200 hours.
Someone from the Camo shack came into the
club instead of Vietnamese team member
from our t ASP was on the
radio talking to spider.
That was very bad news.
Several of the RECON team members in
fob one headed toward the Camo shack.
Before we got there, Tony Harrell,
a veteran recon man came around
the corner with some more bad news.
They were hit by sappers.
It doesn't look good.
[inaudible]
it appeared the American's and bid
slow to react in a matter of seconds.
The sappers killed the three SF troops
and chose to leave the south Vietnamese
team members alive.
The news about the sappers
was a triple dose of bad news.
First we had three dead green berets.
Okay.
Second reports.
One Zeros had received from months about
NVA sappers being a leaf lethal force.
We're now confirmed.
Yeah.
Third, by killing only the Americans.
The NVA pulled off a major psychological
coup by leaving the envy that by
leaving the Vietnamese team members alive,
their survival would plant seeds of doubt
and dissension between SF troops and
our little pieces.
Okay,
and then you guys were heading north
the hundred first airborne division.
Choppers carried the six men south when
the choppers landed on the helicopter
pad. Colonel Jack Warren had ordered
every man in fob for out to the site.
Okay.
He was held in high regard by SF troops
because he genuinely cared about his men
[inaudible].
It had been said that because
of his dedication to the
SF mission and the men of
SF, he would never advance
beyond the rank of colonel.
He'd remained an SF too
long, a career decision,
not the traditional army
hierarchy, despised and punished.
ASP was from farb for Fob,
for which Warren commanded.
After the three corpses were
unloaded from the helicopter,
Warren gave a terse teary-eyed
speech to his captive audience.
Okay.
Warren warned everyone that if
they were careless in the field,
death was the result of that carelessness.
Okay.
Then he bent down, opened the body bag,
and picked up a portion of a body
of one of the dead Americans.
He was now crying and screaming at his
men to never be careless in the field.
Warren was never the same after that.
Okay?
Neither was CNC.
What, what was it that
changed from your perspective?
Well, we, um, from our early briefings,
probably in October, we heard
about the NBA soccer teams.
They were highly trained and, um,
they would just wear a
loin cloth, carry a weapon.
And, uh,
they were really just highly trained and
tracking so that when they came to the
TAC part,
they have minimal clothing and they
knew what they were looking for.
And the NBA at that point had a metal
kill American metal. So they killed us.
They got their metal and a bonus and there
would be heroes for the rest of their
lives within the communist party.
So we heard about them disconfirmed
it and it just kicked up everybody's
concerned a notch. And
that being New Year's Eve,
the team had at the Americas had
taken a bottle of Scotch with them.
So they had had little hit of the Scotch.
We don't know how much and that's what
Jack Warren had gone the extra distance
on saying about being
careless. We don't know.
But the sappers were good
and um, that proved it.
And it just gave us an our case
no on, as you know for you,
do you Ron at night without the
dogs he would do your perimeter.
And our people always checked me and we
always had rotated whose be sleeping and
who wouldn't. And we never
ever had a problem with that.
No matter how tired you are to be
somebody awake just so something like that
happened. Somebody be there on
full automatic ready, the respond
new level terror. Yeah.
And those guys were so it's like a just
traveling super light and super select
the sappers sure. You know, just
could move quickly and yeah.
That's a scary uh,
yeah, because you know, the,
we knew that the NBA had all our
sources set up meeting besides being
compromised in headquarters.
They also had people that alerted
when the choppers left along site.
They have border watchers so that when
we came in they would report where we
were heading to a higher command and
they would try to rally their troops.
So we were up against that at all times.
Just a question of who would be there,
how many, and a lot of times just
getting on the ground was the first part,
but then you hope to get into the mission
and it was just really a challenge.
Okay.
Speaking of a challenge who
were going back to the book,
the daily grind of running missions
across the fence was wearing on me
physically and mentally. As 69 dawned,
I began a mental
examination of life in SOG.
Being in an elite unit within America's
finest special operations was where I
wanted to be.
The adrenaline enhanced high of deadly
fire fights against a relentless m enemy
under extremely lopsided
odds was intoxicating.
I had never experienced such
exhilaration or sheer terror
if there was a little voice in the back
of my head, which spoke of survival,
surviving not only a vigorous enemy
campaign directed against a SOG members,
but merely surviving the odds
of going home in one piece.
My mind also began the mental debate
between rising to the new challenges
inherent in a secret war and
returning to a safer assignment.
Okay.
My one year tour of duty was
scheduled to end at the end of April.
Under the general rules of SOG after
running targets across the fence for six
months, I could request
a cushy assignment.
I had already spent seven
months with the team.
I was alive. However,
thanks to hip sow fuck Twan
and the other men STI though.
I couldn't just walk away.
And that's where your, that's
where you wrap up this book.
Now you go into some cool.
Um, you go into some cool,
one more really interesting story.
And then you also have a very cool thing
in there about what you guys carried
and what we didn't care and
what you didn't carry. How
much, so how much longer?
So now it's January of 69. Yeah,
you'd been there for seven months.
How much longer did you
stay with the CNC teams?
I'll stay right there to the end. Um, we,
we closed fob one in January.
They shipped us down to Denang and that's
where I picked up with a second book.
And uh, um, they needed help down here.
So we hit the ground, um, continue to run.
Baba asked if tape be taken off the
team. So he left. Lynn black came on.
So with linen on for my last couple of
months and at the very end they had a
mission up at the mew pass,
which was north of the
DMZ river in layoffs,
which was a major channel point.
And the plan was for us to go in,
set up our mountain top,
taking a lot of claymores mortars and um,
call an airstrikes for two or three days
on that just to raise hell with the NBA
there cause they never had a
recon team go that far north.
And we did an inspection,
which is that inspection prior to that
mission, which was about April 20th, 69.
And then, um,
we finally went up to the
launch site and we were up to,
I guess maybe about the 24th or 25th.
I just forget the exact date now,
but we were up to a launch
site, got on the choppers,
we're getting ready to launch, the
choppers take off. And he turned around,
went back,
and he hit that target had just had
two aircraft shot down over it and they
figured they just shot down a phantom
jet and the sky reader choppers are going
to be easy to knock out this
guy. So to Sidebar to that,
I'm at a reunion two years ago,
one of the guys that ran recon
says, remember those pictures?
You got an f on your second book on the
Ground Air? I said, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He says, what was their mission?
Wasn't that something like that?
A suicide mission, right. And says,
well I don't know about suicide.
I was going to be high odds. But you know,
we were gone and we had two extra
Americans where we had [inaudible].
We got Buku bullets. Hand-Grenades
we were gonna give it a shot.
This guy goes,
do you realize they asked me to do
that and I told him to fuck off. I go,
really? [inaudible] you
saw taking pressure.
You didn't tell me that cause I
didn't know what your mission was.
So here's the top secret operation,
the recon guys, another man,
it'd be given that target said Hell No,
it was too far north and
you've just felt that the, uh,
it would just be a suicide
mission. And once you get in,
you never get out other
than a casket or a body bag.
But there's no talking between teams
much cause everything is like you got a
mission, you do your
mission, they do theirs. So
yeah. Well, uh,
I already gave you a fair warning before
we started this that we're probably
gonna have to have you come back on
here. Cause I mean, I, I got just a,
I mean this, this, these books
are, they're just awesome.
The detail that you go on to and
just the experience that you've had,
which are just,
it's a miracle that you're sitting here
talking and able to tell us what you
went through when, as far as I can tell,
there's no way in hell you should
be sitting here right now. I agree
times when, uh, in talking to friends
who are people that have read the book,
you know, particularly on page two oh
two would the guy touches your boots.
I mean, I've talked to people. It's
just like, it feels surreal even today.
It's like, thank God everybody
at home was praying, you know?
And uh, yeah.
The last thing I want to
read from the book is just a,
just this section right here.
The dedication says this book is
dedicated to all SOC reconnaissance team
members,
both US special forces and indigenous
troops as well as to every man in every
air support unit,
especially the king B pilots of the
219 south Vietnamese air forces,
Special Operations Squadron who worked
daily with SOG teams on the ground across
the fence in America's secret war.
Okay.
This book is also for every man
in SOG and their support units.
Who made the ultimate sacrifice.
Yeah. Because today as we sit here,
there are still 1,589 Americans missing
in action in Southeast Asia from the
Vietnam War. That includes CIA,
s f regular army and lay us alone.
50 Green Berets are amongst
those mias over 140 aviation,
army, Marine Corps, Air Force,
Mias dies supporting our
missions ear just held deleo was,
you guys had a over 100% casualty rate.
Yeah. Several of our guys
have multiple purple hearts.
Bob Howard received eight. He
had been put in for 11. He, he,
he was a recipient of the medal of honor
in December 68 for a mission out of
Kontomble. And uh, yeah,
the Cassie rate did a
seat a hundred percent.
The uh, and I, I didn't,
I couldn't find any numbers on the
numbers that were actually killed,
but that was a massive number
percentage wise of guys in SOG that were
killed. Right. Yeah. The
numbers, um, are hard to track.
Um, I'm working with a
gal now who's a real,
she's a retired master sergeant from the
a hundred first and she's begin to do
some research to, to try to put that
number together because during a war,
3.2 million Americans served in Vietnam.
That includes the 500,000 sailors there
off off the coast and your seals that
were going up north. And
um, out of that 20,000,
approximately 20,000 were
SF out of the SF prostate.
2000 went to SOG out of that.
Depends on which author you talk to.
There's no hard stats anywhere because
SF was not as good as the seals and keep
our records and uh,
it'd be between 500 to seven,
maybe 800 green berets
actually went across the fence
with recon missions out of
the 3.2 million. Those are our numbers.
Yeah. Amazing. Um,
well I hope you don't mind coming back
here and an honor to come back because
for some of your stories, pal, do believe
me, my stories are on a big joke. I,
I conversed with, uh, one of our, one
of the guys that was in Ramadi with me,
a guy by the name of Dave Burke. He was,
he was a Marine Corps ANGLICO
guy on the ground with us.
And you know, we always
joke our about our,
about what are our experiences, you know,
he had a friend and we had him on the
podcast who served in World War II,
Korea and Vietnam. Really,
he was a purple heart recipient in every
war and every one of those wars I had,
you know, uh, that's the way I feel
standing here talking to you. Like I'm,
I'm uh, in a totally different and
much lower category of experience.
But that's why it's such an honor to
sit here and talk with you about this
mutual. If you have any
other closing thoughts too.
Well,
the only thing about this book actually
spot the mentioned that I could've done
it without my wife. Awesome. My
dear wife Anna at the time, um,
we had four teenagers in one
newborn in the house and said,
you can imagine that turmoil and I'm
working that fish wrapper up in north
county and so between the fish
wrapper and the kids, she goes,
go right to book.
Awesome. She supported me all
it. That is one thing real quick.
When you got home from,
so you got out shortly thereafter when
you got done with Vietnam is that that's
when you were done, right? You got
out of the army shortly thereafter?
Yeah, I went back to, to CNC,
a for second tour and then I got out of
the army in April 20 fives with book to
Isabelle. Going back
one tour wasn't enough at CMC.
Well you know what, it be all
honest with you. I came back in, uh,
by the time I landed in the states
like may one, May 2nd of 69,
the antiwar movements going on
strong. Uh, there was Woodstock,
our men walked on the moon, but I hated,
hated being and we were
and are supposed to go to,
to Fort Bragg with the regular SF.
But the 10th Special Forces group was
up in Massachusetts and they had five
companies, a, B, c, d, and
e. He was a signal company,
which was rinky dink.
They had new lieutenants,
butter bars running this thing and
they treat it like basic camp on us up.
And to top it off,
they had old career sergeants that are
all overweight on embarrassment to the
Bra they wore. And they came in and
put me up batoon sergeant and I'm,
I'm in this environment that
was not a good chemistry. So,
um, I heard that the MPS were
coming basically. And uh,
I went down to Pentagon. We
had a woman, Billy Alexander,
who handled our orders as told what
kind of wine and what flower she likes.
So before I went down here,
I had her wine, her flowers,
and a Thursday morning I get to
the Pentagon is seven o'clock,
give her the flowers, no wine, went
back to sleep in a parking lot,
came back and forth. She gave me two
orders to nom. I cleared on Friday,
the MPS came on Monday
and I was back in my team.
40 MPs covered for what are some
bar fights? Property destruction.
They have reports of a four 42,
which I had at a time for
four to w 30 which is what?
Austin Oldsmobile [inaudible]. Oh God,
God. Oh, that for four to go y'all,
sorry. Yeah, it's a 69 which was the
coolest car at the time. You hear me too?
For sure.
There are reports about that car going
through the entrance gate on the sideways
drift. I said, I'm sorry.
When I entered the base on the
exit gate, that's what it was.
The MP's weren't happy about
that. They couldn't catch me.
I was able to hide
within our conquest mint,
but they were trying to begin to
figure things out. But anyways,
they were common. Sounds like, or
it sounds like the next podcast,
that's the warm up for
the next podcast. We'll,
we'll take it from there next time. Like
a bad dream. I'll be back if you ask.
Thank you. No, that's awesome.
These books across the fence,
which one do you think people should ride?
Read first across the fence as the
first and ask my book about my getting
involved,
the next Cetera and the stories of
uh, other people which bought away.
We have a Greenbrae medic, John
Walton who was the son of Sam Walton.
You heard of a store called Walmart
[inaudible] son. We're on the best medics.
There was at the time chapter
four where a fellow green break,
his leg blown off and the front
of Vietnamese got shot four times.
John brought them all back and Tom
Cunningham's alive today and uh,
has two children. Thanks to John.
That's awesome. These books are available
on Amazon, right? Amazon just go damn.
Zonda bill was ebooks or paperbacks.
You know the one who website is saw
chronicles.com saw chronicles.com.
That's the name of volume one.
That's another book, right?
And then on the ground, the secret
war in Vietnam as the second book.
The second book is in here. There's some
stories I missed because of deadlines.
Right?
And the first story we have the our recon
teams and our worst target Oscar aide
and the NBA come up and tap
them on the shoulder and say,
it's your for guard duty.
Oh, that's pretty close
to the enemy. All right.
We will cover these books in the
future. Everyone go buy these books.
Are you ready? And thank you, really a
true honor to have you on. Appreciate it.
Honor to be here. And can we have
you back if you turn outstanding.
Thank you. And with that, Mr
John Stryker Meyer has left the building
and what an honor it was to talk to him
and I can absolutely promise
we're having that guy back on.
And thanks to you, John, for your,
for your service and your sacrifice
and the sacrifices of your teammates.
It is men like you that have allowed us
to live the way that we live in that is
in freedom.
So he has left the building and echo. Um,
speaking of living, living the way we
should live, what do you got for us?
Well as we have been doing,
talking about Jujitsu first
[inaudible] Jujitsu, martial arts,
uh, know
capability is what it is.
That's really what it is.
You want to generalize it like the whole
thing into one big nugget capability.
Just improve the capability. We want to
improve our capabilities. Oh yeah, sure.
Way Too.
Do that. Not just in the Marshall
fields but in life. Yeah.
Is to train some of that Jujitsu.
Yeah, I was talking to, there's a girl
named Kara who trains here, you know,
I see her every once in a while
I'll see or whatever. And um, she,
she said basically the stuff we were
saying where she was like, I was like,
I bet I only see her sort of in
the men's class. I said, hey,
have you tried the women's costs that
are women's class goodness developed?
And then she was like, not yet. I want
to whatever. And I was like, yeah,
that's, I think a lot of the times we'll,
we'll offer more benefits
depending on who you are as a girl,
we'll offer benefits because you can
get like the moves you can kind of do,
you know on on a body that's
more similar to yours.
So you can go through the moves
a little bit more thoroughly.
I think in a way for lack of better
way of putting it. She was like, yeah,
that's good. That's true. She's like,
you know what though, I really like,
there's a lot of value here in,
in the guys in the men's class.
And she said straight for self defense
for sure. And I was like, yeah.
She's like,
yeah because like when you get used to
guys and meanwhile there's like two guys
scrolling like hard though,
you know the kind where they're rolling
and they're grunting at right in front
of us like sweating and split their splits
with flashing on us. And she's like,
when you get with [inaudible] and we
kind of laugh cause w she like motions to
them and I'm thinking like, yeah,
any girl to come in and see that or
anyone even anyone even never dissipate in
that. Yeah. Thinking I got to do that.
No way man. I'm not ready for that.
All girls are not ready for that. Oh yeah.
And what if you would just all of a
sudden like one day you go to the grocery
store and now you've got to
deal with that. Man. That's,
that's tough cause it's a big
psychological gap. You need to make up.
Oh you have to train Jujitsu.
The gap is made up. She was like,
I'm used to and she's
not a big girl either.
She's just like a pretty small girl.
She's like, yeah and he's real nice,
you know, nice to go.
She's like, yeah, I'm cool.
And I'm really used to that and I've
been training for like almost a year now.
I'm like a big difference.
That's good that you can come in here as
often as you do and have that mindset.
That's good. That's going
to get you places 100% so
we're talking about Jujitsu.
Oh yeah.
And then you need to start talking about
the gear that is needed for Jujitsu.
Some of it, yes. Some of the gear
that you need for to do as a g. Yes.
If you're going to train g Jujitsu,
which we recommend strongly,
strongly recommend. We also
recommend you train No-gi.
You train all kinds of Jujitsu. Yeah,
that's what you train. If you need a g,
which you do get one from origin,
main origin, so you go to origin,
maine.com this is where you can
get all these things. Also jeans,
American Denim. Again, we all, we all
know this, but I'm going to say it again.
It's all made in America. All of
it. Yup. Every little piece of it.
The little seeds that they
plant to eventually grow
cotton to eventually go into
the loon to eventually
formulate. We've yes,
formulate both the fabric that gets
sewn and stitched into ghees jeans,
rash guards, all this stuff. Shorts,
the shorts in oral tube, by the way,
factually. Anyway, all of it is in
American done in America. So boom,
there's that huge deal by the way.
So yeah, American Denim hasn't,
we have some new jeans,
good ones, jogger, you know,
sweat pants, sweat, athletic
gear, boom, origin, Maine,
their supplements, big deal.
Pretty much all the essential supplements
that you're going to need as you go
through this kind of hectic path at times
about the sector and should be, yeah,
I kind of cheesy. That's not the path
we want to be on. That path leads down.
It's going to be easy if it's a downhill
situation cause all you gotta do is sit
there and slide, don't take the
path down, you know? So yes,
the supplements are joint
warfare for your joints.
Joint warfare is more for like if
you have get abuse on your joints,
you're running a lot. You,
you're doing jujitsu where you're twisting
a lot and you're going every day or
something like this or you're just lifting
every day lifting everyday. Oh yeah.
Basically if you're doing physical
activity. Yeah, that's Kinda like hard.
I mean, I guess you could
break it down like, Oh,
if you're doing some weak physical
activity then you might not need it.
But I think not that so much the joint
where for you made a good point though,
the muster number.
Cause your knee is like Kinda on the panel
on the final Steven's healing and you
were like, I was like, yeah, how's your
knee or whatever and you're like, uh,
would you say, oh it
was good. But like, oh,
since I've been standing up on
it for a long yeah, sure. Yeah.
At the muster, yes. It actually swelled
up again. Yes, surprisingly. So.
Here's the thing, it made me
think when I was a bouncer,
I used to stand up all the
time. Like for the whole thing,
you're standing at the front door
and not the tactics, the path,
the second and the
struggle is real bad. And,
but I have dress shoes on. I don't have
the, the new balance or the, you know,
the deal, it's like dress shoes.
So it's like it was hurting man.
Joint warfare have came
in handy. Well, you know,
varying levels of hard to get some
joint warfare for your joints.
Get some Krill oil for your joints.
General Maintenance and
general maintenance of life.
Yes. Life support. Yes.
Let me get the, and then discipline and
discipline go, which is sort of like,
um, gives you a little bit of that.
Yeah. A little edge. Mentally
Shotgun. It is illegal.
Negative.
If you are going to confront
someone in an intellectual battle,
is it legal for you to take
discipline? Go and they don't,
should not be illegal because it's not
any legal drug shit. It's not even drugs.
It's actually good advantage
though, right? Yeah. Good.
We lifting weights is an advantage or
the results from lifting weights is an
advantage of the results from eating
salads. That's an advantage. So boom,
same thing. But just the pulling
just tastes really good and uh,
and have that advantage over your
enemy, whoever they may be. Yes.
Then we got up, we also got milk,
which is milk, delicious,
delicious protein.
And I had a milkshake last
night at meatloaf. No potatoes.
Meatloaf, carrots. Milkshake. That's
a good meal right there. Chocolate,
dark. Know the darkness and I put
peanut butter in it. Boom. There it is.
Literally my late dinner
last night, I was 10. Yeah.
That's the milk. And you can
give it to your kids too.
You can get the warrior kid milk.
Yeah. For your kids. So your kids,
so your kids instead of turning out to
be like an obese outage shape kid that
you were like trying to, no,
don't even put them on that path.
Put 'em on the milk tray. Let me ask
you this, when you were young, yes.
And you went to whatever, elementary
school, junior high, whatever.
Did you bring home lunch?
Sometimes. Yeah. So not very often. Okay.
So do you [inaudible] as far
as you can remember, did you,
did you have a healthy home
lunch? Do you, was your, you know,
nothing and we didn't even know
what healthy was. Like it wasn't,
that wasn't even a thing.
Yeah. They were just like,
oh what do you like to eat peanut and
what do you like to eat and what's cheap?
Yes. Right. Cause we're going to get
you, we're not getting you cold cuts.
Right. Cause those costs money. Guess
what? Doesn't cost a lot of money.
Bologna jam. PB and jam.
Yeah. Right. [inaudible]
butter and Jelly. Oh,
two all day long on the on on white
bread. Oh, white bread, white bread.
And then you know what?
You get the little,
the little party mix of of potato chips.
Frito lays Doritos, which
I never liked Oreos.
I still don't like to read
those interests. Yeah,
but then you get some of that and
then like some chocolate chips.
I'm chips Ahoy cookies. You know what
those are? Yes. I do get the sleet,
little little mini sleeve, a chips Ahoy
and so there's nothing nutritional.
Right. There's the nutritional value of
this launch is zero. You had nothing.
Yeah. If that was best case scenario,
I used to get the chocolate milk from
the cost that it costs 5 cents for a
chocolate for a white milk, 7
cents for a chocolate milk. Oh,
at my school school lunch.
Yeah. So I used to get that.
That would probably be when
I actually lived off of,
because everything else was just was just
poisoned in a rapper basically. Yeah.
Does that answer your question? Well, I
mean the reason I was asking is because,
okay, so my family or my mom more
than my dad I guess. But you know,
my mom took care of the poem lunches in
the event of us bringing her home lunch.
She, she's health conscious.
She was like a Hippie, you know,
so we had like the whole
wheat bread. Okay. You know,
and then Novato, you're, how old
are you? I will be 42 this year.
So you're like five years
younger than me. There's a,
there's a difference there in terms of
what people were even thinking. Yeah.
Yeah. We'll keep in mind everyone
wasn't like that. I'm saying my mom was,
my mom was like a hippie. She was
different than everyone. And here's what,
here's my point with that.
Where when we'd come to school
and I'd bring home lunch,
we'd get sorta teased because it's
like you don't get the cool snacks,
the cool Frito lay,
Frito Lay's and chips and cookies
in like the cool fun stuff. Oh No.
And then open the milk
negative. No, you got,
we got the whole wheat sandwich with
like Turkey from a real Turkey with
sprouted grains on it or some little
wheat bread hundred. Sorry about that.
Sprouted grain. That's the
next level right there it is.
It is. Nonetheless. We
got laughed at that end.
Mama Deco was coming in hard with the
sprouted oil rain bread with a health.
Yeah and there was making funny
cause it tastes like cardboard.
I don't even know cause they don't
know how it tastes. It's not tight.
It's more of a social thing. Everyone,
everyone knows that
cookies or young yummy.
Everyone knows that like chips are
delicious for snack and all this stuff.
We didn't have that.
We had like the snacks that they knew
that weren't that good tasting carrots and
like carrots are pretty tasty
though. I think so now. Yes,
concerned about cares. If you're not
eating sugar and you eat a carrot,
taste sweet. Yeah it is. You're like,
oh this is super sweet. Tastes good.
You can eat too many carrots because
your body can't digest them fully if you
eat too many of them. Just FYI.
I've made that mistake before.
Pounding bags, a carrot. I look
like one of those bags. Guards.
Your gut is going to tell you
no. Do an issue. Good. Noted Bro.
Where are you going with all
this? I'm making a good point.
Unless you wanna talking about care. It's
a little bit more, I can't, we can't,
but nonetheless make it a point.
So these kids would make fun of us because
they got the cookies and we had like
tomatoes and sprouts in our sandwiches.
But growing up when you
come early adulthood,
adulthood, that health
consciousness paid off big time.
Huge time check.
So to make the switch from non-health
consciousness to health consciousness,
it's like it's, it can be a grind that
can be harder. Yeah. [inaudible] path.
Maintain the path. And it's already
instilled as being a young person.
So there's that. So milk.
So my daughter comes home from
school literally yesterday.
Say they were teasing me because
I had carrots and she was,
she wasn't very happy about it. I was
due to start token fools out. Well,
I started to say that, but you,
it was no time for jokes at this
point cause she had been like,
are you serious or not? I'm like,
you don't wanna choke anyone for
teasing you for your carrots,
but this is what I said. One
of the things I said, I said,
don't worry about them. T there's no,
first of all there's nothing funny
about carrots like there it's not,
I'm not saying it's like or so serious.
I'm just saying what's funny about
I don't get it kind of thing.
And she was like, yeah, that's kind of
true. And I was like, and guess what?
Carrots are good for you.
Just like your lunch is good
for you and as you grew up,
you're going to see the results of that
and you're going to see the results of
them not eating, not healthy
food. And you're going to see,
you need to do better than
that as a father. Why?
Because you need a better teacher. No,
she needs to be like, they say, oh,
what are you eating? P You eating
some, you eaten some carrots.
And then she says, what do you eat
in there? Some type two diabetes,
you're going to die at age 32
loser. Get out of my face, four,
I put you to sleep all the implement.
You know that that direction is not
part of the way of the warrior kid code
right there. Negative. No, that's
are having fun. Fun is part of life.
But I saw her wheels turning when
she was like, like yeah, you know,
like I will all see the results,
you know, and then you know,
then my wife's there and she's like, yeah
look, you're dead. How big is muscle?
All this stuff, right?
So kind of close or your wife was
kind of like just making stuff up
unless it worked, but go back
to [inaudible] or your kid milk.
This is what you achieved with that.
One of the many things is you actually
made it like kind of cool to have a
healthy thing. Have a healthy snack.
We're going to sway a lot of
people with these books and this,
this stuff is what's going
to happen. I mean, I seen it.
It's not even going to happen. It
is happening. It's awesome to see.
All right dude. We got to rock and roll.
Columbia. That was an important story.
I've got a long weldment anyways,
so we got Jocko white tea. How
about that? Tell me about it.
Drink it tastes good. Dead lift a thousand
pounds certified organic by the way.
Yep.
Certified organic and all that good stuff
and it tastes delicious and it looks
cool. So when you're
good and we have a store,
it's called chocolate store.
So you're going to Jocko store.com
this is where you can get and,
and get rash cards.
You can get tee shirts, Huh?
You can get truckers hats and if you're,
if you're not into truckers hats
cause whatever, you can get.
Flex fit hats. Yeah, Bruh.
Flicks me down if ads are good
though, you don't get to judge hats.
You don't wear hats. They looked
stand down, stand down, stand down
anyway. You want to represent
the pat. This is what it's for.
It's quality stuff's not
ballpark. Give away a shirt.
The one you never wear,
you use for like, you know,
wiping your hands in
the kitchen or whatever.
It's not that you're not gonna want
bands in the kitchen with these straight
about quality, quality,
quality and representation. Um,
so yeah. Listen, women stuff on
there yet. A lot of good stuff.
I'm going to have two more new
shirts coming out. Nice. New.
I don't want to necessarily say just
shirts, but to more new items, things.
Sure. Coming up. Let's stand by
for that. Also. Subscribe, right?
Yes. Subscribe to what?
The podcast for you.
We're not talking about subscribed to
a magazine cause no one gets magazines
anymore. Magazines are dead. Sure.
Right? By a magazine now. Well,
you gotta have somebody bring them a
random bunch of papers to your house with
advertisement. You're not going
to do that. No one is that good.
So you're not gonna we're not talking
about subscribing to a magazine.
Subscribe to this podcast
if you want to. Sure.
If you get value out of it, whatever.
And don't forget about the warrior kid
guys. I just, I got hit. I got hit today.
Yeah, I got to hit kind
of hard. Somebody said,
is the warrior kid podcast
dead? I was like, Ooh,
that stinks. That stinks.
Warrior podcast is not dead,
but the warrior kid podcast,
I need to put more out so I needed a
little bit of time, which I'm making,
but I need to get it done. So yes, while
you're kid podcasts, subscribe to that.
I'll get some new ones in there. Also,
Irish oaks ranch.com
is where Aiden warrior,
kid up in central cow
has his own business.
13 years old running a business. No
big deal. That's what where kids do.
He makes soap from goat milk
so that everyone in the world
can stay clean and don't forget about
youtube. We have a youtube channel.
Did you know that? Yes sir. I did.
And it's called Jocko
podcast and it's on youtube.
So podcast is not just a podcast where
it's audio only on the video version.
You can see us if you want to know
what John Stryker Meyer looks like,
you can watch this on youtube. This is
going to get a lot of views on youtube.
Listen to the John Stryker Meyer
and hearing his stories. Yeah.
So check that out. Also,
Echo Charles makes what he
calls enhanced videos. Yes.
Some people might call them
distracting from the message,
sir. They might.
Some people like them [inaudible]
they have millions of views.
Some of your videos that you've
made, you know that Oh yeah,
I did a lot of views. Well like
I said or like you said, yeah,
you can call them distract
chins on the message,
which I actually won't even
argue with it. Thank you.
But some people look at
it or see it as enhanced.
Oh, put some music on there.
You put it enhances the message.
It's kind of like Kinda like,
you know when you have a dog and you
gotta feed them the heartworm pills,
you know, where are the
pills? The heartworm pills
is good for them. It's good.
That message is good, but sometimes
you got to put it in the food,
you know, so like tastes good.
It's like the message gets to deliver
my messages so hard to swallow that you
have to put like videos around it is
what I'm hearing music around it. Yes.
Sometimes break at the cellos
sometimes. Yes, yes. Hey,
so that's a youtube
channel. Check them out.
And then we also got psychological
warfare, which is on iTunes, Google play,
other MP3 platforms. And
if you want an alarm clock,
that's me talking.
Then you go to psychological
warfare and that's what you get and,
and you'll see that you can use it as
an alarm clock or you can use it as an
emergency, as an emergency air cover. Yes.
Fire support. You're like, I'm not
sure if I should work out right now.
Press play. Yeah. On the,
on the psychological warfare track that's
about not working out and you will get
up and you will go to the gym. Yup. If
you're about to eat some donuts. Yes.
Or some chocolate chip cookies,
right? Sure. Chips Ahoy, whatever.
Chips Ahoy.
If you find a sleeve of random chips
ahoy hanging around somewhere, you know,
use that term for the first time
when it was, it was James Nielsen,
what James Nielsen would talk about
eating a sleeve leaf or just get bathroom.
James Nelson for world's
toughest accountant. Agree? Yes.
Black belt in Jujitsu
for a long time. Oh Gee.
American Jujitsu practitioners teaches on,
on Saturdays here at
victory, MMA and fitness,
which by the way is our gym and San
Diego, California. Do you want to train?
So you know what's funny about that to
where you know how you say, Oh yeah,
to world's toughest accountant.
Any teaches, do, do two, two.
So teaching Jujitsu, that's
a job. Like that's a career.
Like you're a Jujitsu
instructor, but he's like,
he's an accountant but
he just teaches you to,
he's not like an accountant
is like some, you know,
scraping by sort of getting old
and there's a few people like that.
You know why?
Because Teaching Jujitsu is fun and
it makes you better at Jujitsu better.
That's just how it is, man.
The nature of the game that's
on psychological warfare.
Also you can get it if you want some
visual representation of the path to keep
you there. You can go to flipside,
canvas.com run by my brother,
Dakota Meyer. He makes art with layers,
with layers. The layers are free.
Take while they, they're not free.
They come with the cost of the art
layers included, layers included.
There you go. Yes, we've
designed some of the items there.
Yeah. You know, let them know like, hey,
this would be kind of cold right here
and if you want something just just
request to Cota on Twitter I think is
the best place. Yeah, and that's cool.
Flip side,
campus.com if you want to get some
cool stuff to hang up at your house,
back to psychological warfare, to
use that whole thing as a playlist.
Psychological warfare, even
if it doesn't apply to you,
you know you're not eating donuts
Wa playlists while you work out.
Even if you're not eating donuts while
you workout, which most of us do not.
It still like it puts you in
this mindset of like, you know,
working in reaping the
results of work. Yeah.
It goes back to the podcast and machete
season when they talk about how the
power of the audio into
your ear. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what's happening with psychological
warfare going right in your ear.
You like you walk, you
get done. Listen to that.
You're not even thinking about the fact
that you're thinking about the fact
you're what I just said.
You're not thinking about the fact that
you are thinking about the fact that you
don't even want and don't want,
that you want to get in the gym,
that you want to attack your project.
That's what's happening. It's true.
100% true. Also while you're
live, if you're lifting at home,
if we're doing the lifting at
home, which I do, which you do,
which a lot of us do, actually, people
hit me up, show me their home set up.
Awesome. You should have
kettlebells. In my opinion,
kettlebells is one of the pretty much
the biggest as far as changes to my
workout, the most valuable change did
I changed my workout functionality,
functionality like the Benzos word.
One time I was doing a, you know,
you gotta introduce the
risk control, you know,
and bearing levels of risk control
depending on the position there.
I was rolling with the guy literally
like he's like trying to release my grip
from his wrist or whatever and like
he's visibly angry because he couldn't.
So I just sort of sat there and
just let them like do it, whatever.
That was his technique cause technically
you should be able to get out of that
shit.
But I've been doing those kettlebells
so my risk control is a lot.
We'll say the effectiveness is a lot
higher on the less original point
kettlebells, this is where I
get my kettlebells from on it.
So you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
Jocko there you can get these kettlebells
and they're all the cool ones too by
the way. Like always say Darth Vader.
My most recent one, storm Trooper
Kettlebell, my second most recent one,
and not to mention all the other primal
bells and legend bills that I have from
there.
Also at on it is the
electrolyte mineral mix.
That's part of my daily mega
mix with Jockos discipline.
Like I said, the mineral electrolyte mix
water, maybe a little Gatorade.
If, if I'm feeling a little feisty
and oh, that's how you take a joint
warfare and Krill oil. Don't, don't,
don't drink Gatorade. Everyone
here, we got some books too.
We got way of the warrior kid
three where there's a will.
It's out right now and for everyone
that's gotten it so far, awesome.
Appreciate it. Write some reviews
so that I know what you think of it.
That that is cool.
If you have worried your work where we
have the where kid three where there's a
will,
that means you should also have way where
the word kid one and two number two is
called Mark's mission. Also,
we've got Mikey and the
dragons best children's book
ever written according to a
lot of people. A lot of people dig it,
lot of evil and tell me that
I understand tons of people.
Uh, no, seriously, check out Mike in the
dragons. Help your kids overcome fear.
Fear of all kinds. Also got the
discipline equals freedom field manual.
If you need to know how to get after it.
If you want the audio version of that,
it's on iTunes, Amazon
music and Google play. Also,
we got extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership written by myself and
my brother Leif Babin
extreme ownership number one,
the selling business book. Since
it got released the whole time.
We just got that little stat. Dang. It's
kind of cool. That's a big step. Yeah.
Yeah. Some people
tell me that dichotomy
of leadership is better.
[inaudible] it's a good
combo. I'll leave it at that
Asheville on front. That is
my leadership consultancy.
What we do is solve problems through
leadership. It is me, Leif Babin,
JP Denelle, Dave Burke, Flynn Cochran,
Mike's Really Mike
[inaudible] and Jason Garner.
If you need help in your
organization with your leadership,
which will help everything that you
do in your business and your life,
go to Ashland, front.com for details.
If you want to come to the muster,
you already missed Chicago. It was sold
out. Your next opportunity is Denver,
December, uh, or sorry,
September 19th and 20th that is
gonna sell out. And then December
4th and fifth in Sydney, Australia,
if you want to come to it,
sign up as quick as you can so that you
can actually go and you don't get all
mad. You'll be mad at me outwardly.
But deep inside you'll know that you
hesitated and you procrastinated and you
just didn't get your game on. And
that's why you're not at the muster.
So if you want to come to that check,
extreme ownership.com ETF online
leadership training is not an inoculation.
It doesn't take one shot
and now we're good to go.
You want to follow up with it and
that's what you can do with ETF online.
Or if you can't make it to the monster
for whatever reason, go to Yelp, online,
online, interactive leadership
training. Check that out.
If online.com and of course
we have e f Overwatch.
If you have a company and you want to
get some good leaders that understand the
principles of extreme and they're going
to apply them inside your organization,
go to f,
overwatch.com we will deliver you a leader
from the special operations community
or the combat aviation community that is
ready to step into a role and lead your
company to victory. Also,
if you want to hear more
about important things like Hawaii five-o
or other highly intense shows from Echo
Charles or if you want to hear about
leadership in Warren in
human nature from me,
between the two of us, we are on Twitter,
we are on Instagram
and we are on d Foshay.
Echo is at echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and
thanks to all the veterans out there,
especially those like John Stryker Meyer
who volunteered and volunteered
and volunteered again to
do the hardest missions
in the worst areas for zero
recognition by the way,
not even from your own friends and family.
Those are true heroes and we
are forever indebted to them.
We are also indebted to police
and law enforcement, firefighters,
paramedics, EMT dispatchers,
correctional officers, border patrol,
secret service, all first respondents.
Thanks for keeping us safe here
at home and to everyone else.
I know that life can be stressful,
but chances are you aren't surrounded by
elephant grass that is 12 feet tall and
burning and closing in on you.
Chances are you aren't being
assaulted by NVA soldiers.
Chances are you aren't facing death,
but at the same time,
actually you are facing death.
We are all facing death. So remember,
like John striker, Myers said,
every breath of air is sweet.
Yeah.
Yeah. And our gift is to be alive.
So go out there.
Okay.
And live. And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko [inaudible].